Fighting the nonsense of the world.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
the Godfather's back high.
Then anybody can get to see you.
What's going on?
I'm here in southern California,
shaped.
I escaped minus 30 with windshield last
week.
Didn't leave the house from Friday to
Monday with the wind chill factors minus
30 or it's actually minus 30 with the
Windchill,
so I'd say it's minus 15.
Would windshield minus 30?
You guys have become too soft and
southern California.
One hundred percent.
What do you mean become been too soft?
Yeah.
This is a ridiculous place to live.
Well,
I don't know about that.
Is this is like a lottery winner place
to live.
It's like the weather lottery and these
people,
they don't understand what weather is.
They're just running around.
I swear to God.
If it gets 50 here,
people start complaining that I've seen
weather advisories when I used to live
here,
whether it'd be a 10 minute spell of
rain and they'd be endless warnings.
Be careful.
Careful,
careful.
Be careful.
You know we go through blizzards.
There is one reason for that though.
The oil slick on.
Yeah.
When it doesn't rain for a long time,
all the oil from people's cars,
the residue gets on the road and as soon
as just a little bit of water gets on
that it gets really slippery and that
that is reality,
but still before we start,
before we said last time when I was
here,
it was on your birthday and some guy
wrote in a very non Semitic way,
here it goes,
God being a Jew not giving Joe Rogan a
gift on his birthday.
So I thought that I would correct that
by giving you a signed copy of one of my
books.
So there you go.
There you go.
To consuming instinct.
Now you can grow.
What?
Juicy Burgers,
Ferrari's pornography and gift giving
reveal about human nature.
There you go,
buddy,
by and signed by the Godfather.
So very exciting.
Yeah,
well you can't read those.
Those things that people say those mean
things.
I try to avoid them,
but once in awhile I get sucked in and
they can piss me off.
Well,
I always equate it to snake venom.
It's like a.
If you get a little bit of snake venom,
you get you get immune to it and get
accustomed to it.
Whereas if you get a big burst of it,
it can poison you,
so if you just get a little bit of it
every now and then when a big burst
comes your way,
like someone calling you,
achieved you until you go,
you motherfucker,
it doesn't work anymore.
You know,
he just realize there's a lot of people
out there that a lot of the reason why
they're saying these mean things because
they're trying to find something that
they can say that will get you to
respond.
Exactly.
Right.
That's a big part of it.
So what.
So recently,
the latest one is.
So somebody trolls you endlessly in a
very polite manner.
Right?
Okay.
Usually I,
sometimes I try to engage them,
but I find them really.
I know it's ridiculous,
man.
You're again,
you're an actual professor.
I am in the legitimate university.
I'm indeed.
Isn't it crazy that I would even
entertain their Saturday.
So once in a while I get sucked into the
trap there and polite.
So after awhile I blocked them.
So these guys then,
because I've blocked them,
start going around saying,
well,
you know,
he,
he's a supposedly a proponent of freedom
of speech,
yet he blocks me as though I'm the
purveyor of freedom of speech,
right?
I mean,
I'm not allowed to come to your house,
breaking into your house and start
calling you names and if you stopped me,
I accuse you of not supporting free
speech.
Right?
But in their minds,
if I block them simply because I no
longer want to engage them,
I am going,
I am being a hypocrite because I'm not
supporting their freedom to insult me.
See,
again,
I have to go back to what I said
earlier,
why you're so smart.
Like what,
what,
how is this even getting into your mind?
Can I tell you what it is?
Oftentimes,
yes.
I find that galling that somebody could
be so insulting calling.
Does that word mean like a,
right?
Yes.
Right.
I mean we interact.
You and I with a million people a day
with most of the people.
They're lovely.
They're sweet,
they're polite.
They might.
Vast majority.
Right?
So.
So when you get this individual who
simply can't modulate his behavior to
even sort of adhere to the most basic
social norms,
once in a while I just get pissed off,
but usually I'm able to avoid it.
Well,
you shouldn't even once in a while,
look,
first of all,
you got to realize that an anonymity is
a really confusing thing for people,
right?
It's the ability to communicate with
people.
Anonymous has never existed before,
right?
Other than some serial killer,
making some note by cutting out little
pieces of paper or the newspaper and you
know,
using the words from that,
there's no anonymity man.
It doesn't.
It doesn't exist.
Right?
So when you have anonymity in the form
of like you have a twitter account and
it's just an egg and you call yourself
fuck mcgee and you just start trolling.
The Godfather makes no sense.
It's,
well it's,
you know,
that's not a normal interaction.
It's the,
there shouldn't be a method or someone
could just contact you like that because
our,
our bodies and our minds and our,
all our systems,
our social systems,
they're just not set up for that.
So it's,
it's saying rude things without
consequence,
you're,
you're basically,
you're offering,
by the way,
an evolutionary argument.
Yes,
that's exactly right.
But it's a completely new thing that we
really just don't have the mechanisms
for which we're not.
We're not accustomed to it.
We don't really have a long history of
it.
I mean we have a history of just doing
this.
The realistic history at the extreme
level is 20 years,
94 dash 96 ish,
somewhere around then when it started.
Right.
But the real history is probably less
than 10 of it really being incredibly
pervasive the way it is today.
Like with twitter and facebook and all
this instagram comments and things along
those lines.
Go ahead.
No,
no.
I was just saying it's,
it's a new thing that we have to work
out because it is a massive,
massive part of our culture.
There was some statistic recently about
the amount of data that people produce
in a day
worldwide and the most of the data is
lol fuck you,
you know,
bullshit.
But it is ones and zero's,
binary code,
it's all,
all that data.
There's more produced in a day,
then it's some staggering statistics
than the rest of human history.
It's something crazy.
You hear it.
Here it goes every day,
two point five quintillion bytes of data
created daily.
What in the fuck is that?
Ninety percent of the world's data today
has been created in the last two years
alone.
Wow.
By the way,
a lot of business schools now have
programs and data analytics or big data
where they try to teach students how to
navigate through the complexity of this
type of big data sets.
So it's a really hot field in business
schools.
Well,
it's impossible.
I mean the real navigate,
I mean what,
what it is,
is there's a pattern,
a very clear pattern emerging and that
pattern is of anyone being able to
access any information at any time and
it's getting closer and closer to that
all the time and some of that means
communication doesn't just mean being
able to access,
you know,
googling some facts or some,
some knowledge.
It also,
it's being able to communicate with
people.
Right.
And it's got.
It's gotten to this really crazy place.
Speaking of Information,
my doctoral dissertation more than 20
years ago was about how do people decide
when to stop acquiring additional
information and commit to a choice.
So I suppose I'm choosing between cars
or between mates or between job
applicants or between jobs to take
whatever the decision is.
You just say between mates mates.
Yeah know.
So you've got like a gang of bitches for
the.
You should see.
I did.
I did look at some of the comments right
after I appeared.
Right then I lose interest in.
I don't,
but there was one guy who wrote
something like,
this guy is swimming in pussy.
Well,
and then everybody starts ganging up on
that comment.
So you know what it is,
man,
it's a beer commercial.
The most interesting man in the world is
that I looked like what it is like that
look like it's become a thing now,
you know,
got the beautiful white beard and a man
of wisdom and years of.
Thank you.
Uh,
so anyway,
so in that,
in my doctoral dissertation I had looked
at,
well I think I'm better looking at this
guy knew that,
you know,
that guy's Canadian too.
Has He?
He's not even really Spanish and he's
much older than me.
Do you think so?
What do you mean?
Yeah,
I think so.
He's like 70,
51.
I don't know how old the guy goes.
Yeah.
So anyways,
so,
so the whole psychology of decision
making,
I've,
I've addressed that in my research.
Very interesting stuff.
Yeah.
Well what is the.
Well this is a different sort of a
decision making thing because I,
I think you,
you definitely can get lost where you
can just go online and you know,
one of the things that youtube does now
that makes it really difficult is you
watch a video.
So if I was watching some video today on
a rhino slamming into a car,
it was,
it was removed though some copyright
infringement.
It's fucking crazy.
This rhino charge this car and slams
into it.
The problem is once you watch a video,
immediately after that it offers up
another video and it starts playing,
it'll give you like 10 seconds and then
it starts playing again and then you
look on the side and there's all these
suggestions.
It's not as simple as one video.
It's an endless web.
That's why by the way,
Internet pornography for men,
it's such an alluring trap,
right?
Because our visual system and our need
for variety seeking is there and now you
mean I can say she ate this by going
online,
having endless different new bile ready
to meet women.
So it's easy for our computational
system to be personalized by,
by the Internet.
Well,
it's also,
it's probably really not.
We're not really set up to watch people.
Fuck,
you know,
it seems like the brain just doesn't
know what to do with,
you know,
especially if you're by yourself close
the door,
what's going on here?
Yeah,
I mean there's people that just will
watch pornography 10,
12 hours a day and it's not just a few.
I bet if you could highlight,
I bet if you were in a plane and you're
flying over the United States and there
was a light bulb that went off over
everyone's head that jerks off 12 hours
a day,
you can be done.
You'd be stunned.
He'd be able to read by.
You'd be able to hold a magazine up to
the window and read.
I,
I'm not joking.
I think.
I think there's a lot of people out
there that get it.
They get overwhelmed by the
possibilities of doing that.
Like the the choice.
Yeah,
it's they don't have the discipline to
handle that and I was actually a
conversation that I was having with my
friend Duncan the other day about
discipline and how important discipline
is to living a good healthy life and
that getting the things that you need to
get done will allow you to actually
enjoy your free time.
Whereas if you don't get those things
done,
the free time in those pursuits,
these things,
they almost become obsessions and you,
you kind of dive into them to avoid the
pressure of getting those things done
and it becomes sort of counterintuitive.
I counterproductive.
Yeah.
Going back to the pornography I had on
my youtube channel,
a genuine Mercedes careeredge sure.
Yeah.
I've met her.
Have you?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She came to one of my shows with a,
I guess I guess her husband or boyfriend
or something like that.
Very nice guy.
He's very smart girl,
but I'd seen her on,
um,
Gavin McInnes his podcasts and she's
very smart.
She,
well,
of course otherwise.
I mean,
what would we have to talk about?
Right.
She's an engineer's an engineer.
She's very,
very heavily vested into the whole
social justice warrior bullshit and the
other way we were fighting against.
Exactly.
So I'd seen her on a few,
you know,
popular podcasts and I thought,
I mean she's just normally sheep,
of course.
Beautiful.
But so well spoken and so I had her on
the show and we've communicated since
several time and so that's been really
fun.
I mean when,
I mean sort of to mimic what you do with
your podcast of bringing in so many
interesting people and my youtube
channel,
I've had people from guys who fight
Islam to porn stars who used to be
former engineers,
so it's been really fun to meet all
these people.
Yeah.
There's a cool movement going on now
where there's a lot of very intelligent
people that are resisting nonsense where
they're just going to come on,
you're wasting time,
you're wasting effort.
And also there's a lot of people that
are attaching themselves to these
ridiculous movements just because they
have an identity in that movement and
then they.
They filled the void.
Whatever social void they have in their
life with this new thing,
this new being an sjw.
I'm a social justice warrior.
There was an article recently about
Yale,
about students at Yale having a hard
time balancing out their social
responsibilities with.
I'm like,
what fucking activism?
This is an activity.
You're just holding up signs and
complaining,
right?
I mean,
this isn't,
does not activism.
You're not.
You're not changing a goddamn thing
other than people's opinions about you.
Have you seen the one with the site?
I did a lecture at University of Ottawa
on the thought police and political
correctness.
I'm not.
I'm not sure if you saw it,
if not,
you know.
Yeah.
It's really,
it kind of covers the,
the safe spaces at the microaggressions
and the,
the trigger warnings.
And one of the examples that I picked,
I really tried to pick some really
outlandish examples that should only
belong in the onion.
One of the examples was some,
I think it was some students at
University of Oregon wanted to take down
the classic quote by Martin Luther King,
you know,
the,
I have a dream stuff.
Yes.
Because it was insufficiently inclusive
by him,
you know,
focusing his Ayer on racism and not
looking at whatever it is,
transgenderism and so on.
Uh,
he was,
he was being divisive.
So when Martin Luther King can draw the
ire of these guys,
none of us are safe.
No one is safe.
Yeah.
Well,
they're not safe either.
I mean they're eating themselves,
they're attacking ourselves.
We had this a podcast where we went over
the story about this woman who joined
Wellesley College,
which is an all girls college I've
spoken.
I've spoken there.
You Do,
you know the story,
but the woman joined Wellesley college
and then once you joined the Wellesley
College,
she decided that she's going to identify
as a man masculine of center,
Gender Queer is what?
Her distinction.
Your stick on it cracked egg up in my
house.
I was crying,
laughing.
I was screaming,
laughing because then she voted to be.
She wanted to be the head person of
diversity,
Chairman Deborah,
whatever the fuck
this the title was,
but it had something to do with
diversity and they were boycotting her
because now she was a white man.
Like this is glorious.
This is glorious there.
They're literally eating themselves.
They're.
They're so ridiculous.
They've spun around in circles and
they're biting their own assets.
It's what's going on,
but I.
I truly feel though that they've sort of
reached a zenith and it's going to start
decaying.
No,
it's crazy that he's going to get worse,
crazier and crazier,
and then there's going to be.
There's a culture war,
right?
Yeah.
I don't think they've stopped.
I don't even think they've started.
I think they're just there right now.
Scrambling.
I think they don't.
They don't hold weight amongst rational
people anymore,
but that's not gonna stop their
movement.
Their movement will continue to be
irrational at a frenzied pace and they
were literally going to cannibalize each
other.
So what do you think is the end
trajectory?
I mean at some point it has to crash,
right?
Well,
it's gonna like it's almost like a civil
war,
right?
It's almost like a preposterous civil
war.
Like I think in a sense our politics in
this country have always been a civil
war just by nature of having only two
choices just by the dual party system in
this ridiculous idea that there's
independent parties.
They're,
they're,
they're not,
they're not independent.
Unless trump decided to go independent,
he's going to win.
You think is going to win the to win?
Yeah.
He's gonna win to Hidden Hillary.
Can't beat him.
I don't think she could beat him.
I,
I would like to see Bernie Sanders when
not,
not because of his financial policies,
which I think are ridiculous,
but I think his social policies are
interesting and what I should clarify
this is,
well,
here's what's ridiculous about his
financial policies.
Don't make more taxes because more taxes
just means more government,
more government is not when we fucking
need right now.
If you want to organize charitable
institutions that will legitimately help
people and have people donate money and
have people work towards,
uh,
you know,
like these donations will actually take
away from your taxes.
Let's quit.
Let's figure out some way where we make
it beneficial for people to be
charitable where we set up community
programs.
It takes some of the money that we're
spending on shit that we really don't
need to spend money on,
some subsidies that we probably don't
need that there are benefiting gigantic
corporations and instead use those to
help the education systems in poor
communities.
Use those to try to provide jobs and
industry and poor communities.
That's.
These are all really good ideas.
So I'm,
I'm in favor of that kind of socialism.
I'm absolutely in favor of free
universities,
right?
I don't think that people should get out
of school and be a quarter million
dollars in debt.
I think that's madness.
I think if you're going to make $50,000
a year,
okay,
if you've got a really good job,
you make $50,000 a year,
right?
You get out of school,
if you,
if you could ask school and you make 50
grand a year,
you're fucking kicking ass,
right?
Everything is going great for you.
You're not really making 50 grand.
You make it about 34,
right?
And then you've got taxes,
you got sales taxes.
If you live in a place like California,
you've got state taxes,
so you're living off of somewhere in the
late twenties,
thirties,
something like that.
And you've got $250,000 of debt you've
got to deal with.
And you've studied women's studies,
which is a very actionable,
a set of skills.
Well,
how many people study that?
Wellesley?
There's a couple.
I mean,
there's,
I just think that it's an insane burden
to put on young people,
to have them enter into the free market,
enter into the world and be already
saddled down by insane amounts of debt.
I think there's gotta be a way around
that and I don't think that it's a
terrible idea to have publicly funded
universities.
I just don't think it's a terrible idea.
I don't think it's an insurmountable
idea.
So I like Bernie Sanders and a lot of
ways.
I think he's a compassionate guy.
I think he's an open minded guy.
I think he says a lot of really radical
things.
I love the fact that he goes out on a
limb with this black lives matter stuff.
I've liked that he's making a big deal
about these cops shooting these young
black kids and then it's got to fucking
stop.
It's gotTa stop.
It's madness.
How many videos have to come out before
you after a while you're like,
well,
there's obviously some clear problem.
How is,
how is trump not handling this?
How is Hillary not handling this?
Like,
this is a real problem in our culture,
in our society,
there's a divisiveness,
there's this separation between these
people that live in these communities
that are terrified of the police and
they're really worried about being shot
all the time and then everybody else is
on the outside looking in and saying,
well,
if you just follow the law,
you wouldn't have those problems.
Like,
well,
try being born there,
try being raised there.
These are,
these are not.
We're not on an even playing field.
You know,
and I think he's one of the few guys
that's addressing this imbalance,
this social imbalance is cultural
imbalance.
This is economic imbalance that we have
in this country in a really radical way.
So I liked him for that.
I think that would be a good thing for
this country.
For a guy like that,
you know,
would just,
would it,
would it really happen?
I don't know.
I mean I take him over the others,
I'd take him over the other ones,
I think trump is just,
he says too much crazy shit.
This shit he said about Mexico,
like they're going to pay for that wall,
and they called me up and they said,
what do you think about this and how
could you say that?
You know what?
The Wall just got 10 feet higher.
That's not what we need.
I mean,
he's not very presidential in his,
uh,
oh man.
His mannerisms,
you know,
I think he's a real successful guy and I
think what he's doing is he's tapping
into this real frustration that a lot of
people have and that's,
there's a lot of people that don't like
the bullshit that's involved in politics
or people aren't seeing what they're
really think.
So here's this guy who comes along,
he doesn't need anybody's money.
He's insanely wealthy.
Yeah.
He's a multibillionaire.
And he could say whatever the fuck he
wants.
And he's used to say whatever the fuck
he wants.
And every time he does it,
people cheer.
So that's good too.
It's good too because finally we've got.
It's almost like we've got an insane
Ross Perot.
Remember Ross Perot,
Ross Perot fucked up the election for
Georgia to,
with the big ears.
He fucked it up for George Bush's Dad.
Yeah.
The older Bush,
you know,
they,
they slated him for a second term.
A lot of people thought he was going to.
When Ross Perot came along and explained
on television,
he bought a half an hour prime time tv
Pre-internet,
ladies and gentlemen.
He bought a half an hour prime time TV
and explained to the Federal Reserve to
people and explain how you're getting
fucked.
And I remember there was no internet
back then.
So I remember me and some friends we got
together afterwards and we were,
we were going,
did you fucking see you then?
Like,
is that right?
Is what he's seeing true.
I kind of had to make any sense.
And then he was talking about how his
children were being threatened and he
was worried they were going to get
kidnapped.
There's all this crazy shit and it got
me down a lot of rabbit holes,
you know,
like conspiracy theory,
rabbit holes,
watching that guy do that.
But I think that what Donald Trump is,
is like a more rabid informed version of
that and more informed,
meaning our culture is more informed,
more.
I mean,
you know,
we're,
we're hearing the,
the age of the Internet where it's,
if you go up on television,
say something about the Federal Reserve,
people understand that you're talking
about an insane institution now.
Whereas back then people are like,
what?
What is he saying?
The Federal Reserve is not a part of the
government,
you know,
like nobody knew that.
Nobody knew that federal bank was it.
Why is it called a Federal Bank of.
It's not federal,
you know,
it's so confusing.
You know,
I think
the main thing about trump that people
are tapping into is rightly or wrongly,
that he comes across as authentic.
So if you look on the,
on some metric of authenticity between
Hillary,
Hillary Clinton could not be any more
inauthentic,
right?
I mean,
she,
she freaks you out,
right?
She,
she spooky in her inability to convey,
even if she tried to fake genuine
emotions.
Whereas on the other hand,
uh,
whether you like him or don't,
trump seems to speak from the heart to
the extent that a lot of people are
disillusioned with politicians.
Then this guy comes along and I can at
least tap into that and,
and hang on that element of his
personality.
So I think that's what explains his
success.
Yeah.
And also white men,
meaning,
yeah,
there's a lot of white men out there
excited to have this,
this really bold white man as a contrast
effect.
You mean to,
to Obama?
Yeah.
As a contrast to Obama.
Definitely a contrast to Hillary and
Bernie Sanders is chumming up with the
black folks,
you know.
Have you seen,
have you followed our politics in
Canada?
Yeah.
You're trudeau guy.
I like that guy.
You do?
I do.
I liked that guy because he's young and
he seemed smart and he has nice hair.
He's got beautiful hair.
He,
he boxed.
He did do that.
But what's bad about them?
Uh,
to the extent that I think we both
despise social justice warriors,
the ostrich brigade,
the regressive left explained the
ostrich burger is a term that I
popularized,
which basically refers to folks who have
their head in the sand so that they
can't really,
except some of the most basic
regularities in the world,
right?
Uh,
you know,
there is no link between Islam and any
terrorist act anywhere in the world to
suggest otherwise it'd be Islamophobia.
Exactly.
So somebody who,
who exhibits this type of behavior as a,
as an exhibiting ostrich logic,
right?
So Justin Trudeau is the kingpin of the
Ostrich Brigade.
Dammit.
Yeah.
Handsome.
So he,
he,
he basically his dad,
his dad instituted as part of our
Canadian he multiculturalism.
Multiculturalism means two different
things.
Multiculturalism.
When it's used in everyday language,
it means that many cultures,
right?
La is multicultural,
meaning it's pluralistic,
but multiculturalism as a political
philosophy is actually a very dangerous
idea,
right?
It basically says that when immigrants
come into your land,
they don't have to assimilate within
your cultural values.
Rather,
you allow everybody to get ghettoize
because who are we to judge the values
of another ghettoized?
Yeah.
Like you mean like a Dominican
community?
The Muslims are here to.
North Korea is on here here,
but ghettos like poor.
No,
no,
no.
Ghettoize in the sense that everybody
who is of the same background lives in
that space.
It doesn't,
that's not a ghetto.
I mean the term is used in different
ways.
It's not ghetto in the,
in the sense of hip hop gets zero.
A term ghetto.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
Because I've always,
I mean,
I'm just saying ghetto in this country
is always referred to as a poor
community.
Uh,
no,
I think it has a broader meaning at
least as I understand that.
So for example,
if you say you'll get to realizing
people into different areas of the city.
I've never even heard it as a verb.
Well,
that's why I'm here to get toe eyes.
There you go.
Yeah.
Here we go.
New immigrants still tended to get a
wise in the cities.
Is that.
I mean it's exactly what I just defined.
Yeah.
What's the origin of ghetto a?
I don't know that it.
Is it,
is it actually based on the word ghetto,
I'm guessing?
Or is it totally.
Is it like.
No,
I like read,
read,
brace yourself folks.
I'm going to say a word that's
confusing.
Niggardly and it has nothing to do with
the n word.
Yes.
It has to do with like find the origins
of that word because I think it has to
do.
It's,
it's about being miserly or cheap.
Yes.
But it has nothing to do with black
history whatsoever.
Reluctant to give or spend stingy and
miserly.
Um,
and the origin.
What's the origin of it?
Whereas this say,
does it say no?
Doesn't have an origin.
But let me,
if I could finish my point about
Jessica,
please do.
So.
Uh,
so Justin Trudeau,
at one point when he was a member of
parliament,
someone had said that things like a fem
female genital mutilation
and child brides and honored killings
was the type of barbers and that we
don't need in Canada.
And Justin Trudeau's position at the
time was,
how dare you use the word barbarism and
describing other people's cultures.
Right?
So he wasn't offended by having women's
clitoral says cut.
He was offended by people who describe
that behavior as barbaric.
So he is the king of the ostriches.
So he's not a fan of the godfathers.
Oh No.
Or I'm not a fan of his rather.
Oh,
Canada.
Have you followed some of our debates
regarding,
uh,
allowing the,
a sort of open.
Well,
not the open door,
but allowing massive number of Syrian
immigrants.
No,
I haven't followed.
You see what's going on in other
countries.
So of course in Europe they look at our
issue and they sort of say,
come on,
are you serious?
We have 800,000 migrants coming through
to Germany.
You're complaining about 25,000,
but we'll look what happened with
Cologne.
Yeah.
Because the mayor of Cologne,
after these attacks on New Year's Eve
was telling women to dress difference.
Right?
And stay away from men hostage brigade.
That's fucking insane.
I mean that that is a very culturally
diverse area that has existed in a very
peaceful way for a long time until all
the sudden they let in all these
immigrants and they're having a massive
problem with women being sexually
assaulted.
So instead of protecting these women and
trying to do their best to ramp up the
police force or do something to stop it
or make sure that people are safe or
really put it,
put it out there that look,
you're in a new fucking place and if you
want to simulate in our culture,
you've got,
leave these fucking women alone or we're
going to get rid of you.
Everyone who does anything to women in
our country,
we're going to get rid of you.
You can't be here and make people feel
unsafe instead of doing that.
But see,
that's so one of the reasons why I'm
very concerned about the $25,000 coming
in and people say,
well come on.
How many of them are likely to be Isis
members?
But the danger is not only people only
think of Isis members is the danger.
Right?
But when you've got 25,000 people,
of whom a very large majority will
adhere to certain values that are
perfectly antithetical to ours.
Right.
What are your views on homosexuals?
What are your views on religious
minorities and Jews?
If we live in 25,000 Syrians at
statistically speaking,
will they are the more likely or less
likely that they'd be antisemitism?
I mean that's an empirical statement
that we could test,
right?
So it's not only about the fact that how
many of these 25,000 are isis members,
it's how many of these 25,000 people
will hold values that are perfectly
congruent with ours.
And so we have every right.
Without having the threat of being
called racist and Islamophobia over our
head to engage in a discussion on how do
we vet these people?
I mean,
how do you find out what percentage of
those are going to hold views that are
grotesque to us
and then should we be letting them in,
but what are the.
What are the options mean?
What?
How could you possibly find out what
their views are?
You would have to sit down with each one
individually and quiz them,
and then you would have to verify their
claims or their answers.
Well,
at the very least,
I would argue that you should never be
allowed under the guise of your
religious practice to a spouse,
you know,
hateful things,
right?
I mean,
uh,
if,
if you go to a house of worship and that
house of worship is
praising certain things that you and I
would consider genocidal hatred,
then my right to be free of the
genocidal hatred that's coming my way
supersedes your right to practice your
religion of genocidally hating me.
Right?
So that,
that's simply has to be the rule.
And if we don't wake up to that reality,
we're going to have problems.
Yeah,
I would say that that's a very
reasonable statement and I think that
there's a lot of people in this country
that liked to say things like what you
were claiming.
Trudeau said about culture.
Like how dare you criticize their
culture.
Their culture is a bullshit word.
It's human behavior and you're looking
at human behavior.
Some human behavior is acceptable,
is not,
and if it's acceptable in other
countries to eat people,
guess what?
It's not acceptable here.
You can't cook people,
you can't eat them.
We don't allow it.
Right.
Well,
I'll let me,
let me add to that.
The part of multiculturalism is this
idea that all cultures are unique,
distinct and equal in their own right,
and actually that is a truly profoundly
incorrect statements.
Cultures are not equal,
but different cultures are
differentially able to engender
happiness to more or less people,
right?
Yeah.
So,
so if you are part of whatever it means,
Tali bond culture,
you couldn't on average predict that
women in that culture will be less
self-actualized than in western
countries.
That isn't empirically demonstrable
fact.
Yes,
and so the idea that who are we to judge
other cultures,
this idea of cultural relativism which
has part which is endemic of
multiculturalism,
is profoundly incorrect and it has to go
well.
It's a,
it's a blind statement.
It's not a real.
It's not a real statement.
You can't really say that.
It's not.
I mean,
you could look at it economically,
you could look at it socially,
you look at in terms of,
you know,
there's a real good argument that in
this country there's less free freedom
and there is another country's because
more people are in jail,
right?
You could look at it that way.
You can look at the disproportionate
amount of people that are in jail for
nonviolent drug offenses in this country
and say,
well,
this country is obviously a fucked up
place,
and that's,
um,
that's a legit claim as well.
But the idea of numerical value equal
making it equal,
we're all cultures are equal.
That's foolishness.
That's not true.
Not only that,
there's a very real thing going in the
world
where as the age of information washes
upon us,
and I think this is the new age of
information that the age of pure
information as this wash is upon us.
We're seeing massive changes in our own
country and we're seeing massive changes
in our political system.
We're seeing massive changes socially.
And I think this is social justice
warrior thing is sort of a side effect
of that were these disenfranchised
people than some of them may be mentally
ill.
They have a voice,
you know,
some of them,
oh,
let's not say ill imbalanced.
Maybe they're radical because they're
young and idealist and they haven't
looked at all the right ways.
And then one day they'll balance out
like many people have as many young
radicals.
It'd become very rational people in
their fifties and sixties and whatever.
But this,
this thing is taking place here.
And it's also taking place all over the
world.
Well,
where information is being resisted.
That's where we have problems in the
world,
right?
Where fundamental religious values are
superseding the age of information
there.
They're squashing people's ability to
express themselves,
people's ability to try new things,
exploring new things,
um,
their sexual values,
their,
their identities,
all those things.
Like,
as soon as you have like an ancient
fucking scripture,
some shit that was written on animal
skins a thousand years ago.
Like as soon as that is,
is at the head.
And that takes precedent over everything
else because it was supposedly the word
of God or who else?
Someone who talked to God,
whatever the fuck it is that you've got
a problem,
a real problem there because religion,
religion in and of itself is an idea and
it's an idea that is the only one of the
very few ideas that we accept that
literally has no basis in reality.
There's no bay.
It has no basis.
In fact,
it has no basis in anything provable.
And that's why we have this concept of
faith.
Well,
as soon as you have religion that's
dominating information you have,
you have a problem,
you've got a bottleneck.
You got to put up a wall that's put up
for progress.
Now when people develop in that
environment,
you have stifled people just like I have
a friend and him and his wife,
they were Mormons until they were like
40.
And then they decided to slowly.
They literally lived overseas for a bit
and they kind of experienced the world
and they,
oh,
it opened their eyes to a lot of
different things and they decided to
move away from the church.
They're fucking lost,
man.
They're lost.
Like,
they're almost like grownup children.
I think you might've told me.
They're wonderful people.
They're great people,
but the wife is really interesting.
She's very self aware and she even talks
about it.
She says,
I growing up in this really
fundamentalist religion,
I think I developed a really bad way of
looking at things
where I'm easily confused,
easily confused and easily lead,
right?
Like with like a charlatan could,
could take her over or uh,
a cult member could.
Chapter eight of the book I just gave
you,
it's called marketing hope by selling
lies.
And basically what I argued there is
that they are different peddlers of hope
that are successful precisely because
they could sell you hope and the areas
that are most important in sort of
Darwinian insecurities right now to be a
better lover.
How to live forever to be a better
parent.
Right?
Right.
So,
so all of the key Darwinian pursuits
that keep us and keep us up at night,
there is a peddler out there who can
give you the recipe,
whether he be a self help guru,
whether he be a medical quack,
whether he be religion,
and so that's why those products are so
successful because they peddle us hope.
Yes,
but growing up in with religion,
especially fundamentalist religion that
cannot be questioned,
it becomes a real problem because
there's these rigid areas where you're
only allowed to think one way right now.
You develop these patterns in your mind.
Then when you move to a new place,
it doesn't support those ideas and you
want to use genital mutilation.
You want to wrap women up and fucking
mummy cloth and make sure they can't
drive like you want to do that same shit
in Canada that you're doing in Saudi
Arabia,
you got real fucking problem.
That's a real problem.
And Justin Trudeau would say,
who are we to judge their practices?
Whereas what you're saying is you're
against multiculturalism because you are
taking a position against it.
So you don't like Justin Trudeau.
Well,
I'm definitely not against
multiculturalism.
I'm against,
I'm against religious fundamentalism on
a,
on a global scale because I'm not
against God and this is what people have
to understand.
Like I would be the last person to tell
you I have any idea about something that
I have never experienced.
What I've experienced is the afterlife.
I have never.
I am open to the idea that this life is
one stage and an infinite fractal,
like a gigantic,
infinite number of experiences that are
our energy can,
can go through,
answer Jack.
Could that simply be the fact that you
are finding an alternate way,
not through religion,
but through some alternate means to live
on forever?
Well,
exactly right now,
so I could.
I could take this pill called religion
that will grant me a mortality or I
could do your fractal Mumbo jumbo stuff
and it's no disrespect and that could
still get me through it.
Whereas the reality of the
intellectually honest position is that
we really have absolutely no evidence.
This is a very small party that will
last if you're lucky,
85 years and it's profoundly fear
inducing because I want to be coming
back on this podcast for the next 4,000
years,
but I.
It really worries me that I won't,
but it's honest.
It's honest.
To know that you've got 85 years in a
sense it's
liberating because it forces me and you.
If you're an atheist to really carpet dm
at right,
you really have to seize the day because
there are no do overs,
there is no eternity,
there is no afterlife.
It's all right here.
What we do,
and so in a sense there is a a glory to
the finiteness that is afforded by
atheism.
You can certainly look at it that way.
My,
my perspective though is that we really
just don't know and that energy
continues to move forward in a lot of
different ways.
We see this throughout all of nature.
Whereas things die.
They get reabsorbed into the ground.
The very energy and the essence that
they had when they were alive fuels all
these different microbes and bacteria
and the ground that it makes.
The soil richer,
grows more plants.
Animals eat those plants that nourishes
them.
They all,
they literally the cells and the carbon
from every fucking human being on this
planet came from a star that exploded.
Death becomes life and some sort of
strange way,
but I don't think that it's impossible
that that could be the same thing with
consciousness,
with energy,
with,
with whatever the fuck it is inside of
us that makes us alive and aware and
makes our minds tune in to all of the
possibilities in the wonders of the
world.
I don't know if this is the end,
but you don't either.
I don't.
Well,
no one does,
right?
That's the point.
And then as soon as someone comes along
and tells you,
they do know,
and this is the only way to the
afterlife,
this is the only way to heaven.
You got a real problem.
You got a real problem because human
beings are malleable and you can guide
them and you can direct them and you can
mold them and you could turn them into
religious slaves.
You could turn them into ideological
slaves and we should recognize that from
a psychological perspective,
from an educated perspective,
from a perspective of recognizing cult
behavioral.
I was watching this thing on this guy,
Steve Hassan,
the guy who was on our podcast before
was a cult expert.
He sent me an email today and I watched
this,
this piece on on cults and cult behavior
and cults on the Internet and it's so
fucking.
It's terrifying how malleable people's
minds are and how someone who's an
unscrupulous person or unscrupulous
person or someone who has nefarious
ideas can convince people to blow
themselves up to get virgins in the
afterlife.
I mean,
that's a reality.
Very earthly Darwinian things in her
life,
right?
Well,
it's the people don't know and that's my
point and when someone comes along and
says,
I do know and this is the truth,
it becomes a real problem because you
can't fucking prove it.
You can't prove it.
You don't have any facts,
you don't have any data.
There's nothing you can measure.
There's nothing you could way and you're
not saying you think you're saying,
you know,
and if you think one thing,
if you think,
I think this is it,
Carpe Diem,
live for the day.
This is our only shot here.
You might be right,
or this guy who's done a fucking pound
of mushrooms might've come back from the
other side and say,
listen,
I have this idea and I think that love
is eternal and it goes on forever,
and then what we really are
here we are this being that's trying to
figure itself out in this very brief
amount of time and the best we can do is
leave behind information.
We have this wonderful thing called
communication and language.
We store this information.
The next generation comes along and
tries to pick up where the last
generation left off,
gather up as much data as they can and
then move it forward a little bit before
they expire and we keep doing it and
doing it and doing it and doing it until
hopefully we move towards some level of
enlightenment as a species.
See,
I can.
I can repackage that in slightly more
earthly and less esoteric terms.
I think that we can achieve immortality
and quilts in two ways,
right through genetic propagation.
That's why you and I have children.
I mean literally we are extending our
genes and also through mimetic
propagation and mimetic propagation is,
you know,
you read this book and now infects your
brains.
I'm not reading it now.
You're not effecting me man.
By the way,
next time I come,
there's a 100 percent final exam on this
book.
So you better professor made exams right
here,
like a cheat sheet or so.
So I'm the medic.
Propagation is basically anything that
can be part if you like,
of your legacy.
Right?
So the collection of stuff that people
can go and and watch about you as part
of Joe Rogan's,
mimetic propagation and long after you
may be gone,
people will be able to consume Joe
Rogan's ideas and all of the wonderful
things that he's done for many,
many years to come.
And so in that sense,
I think either through genetic
propagation or mimetic propagation,
we,
we can be immortal and that's why it is
really important to do all the wonderful
things that people do.
Because that is your ticket to
immortality.
I don't.
I mean,
again,
you might say,
well,
how do you know?
I don't know,
but until I have any evidence of
otherwise,
I'm going to take the intellectually
honest position and say the party is
going to end.
Well,
it really,
let's get further than that because
immortality is nonsense.
This fucking son doesn't have an
immortal life.
Yeah,
we got it for 4 billion years,
right?
If we're lucky,
and that's assuming that we don't get
hit by one of these gigantic fucking
rocks and keeps flying around.
You hear about that one that went off
over the Atlantic Ocean the other day?
No.
Oh my God.
The fucking media exploded over the
Atlantic Ocean.
Nobody knew about it.
Nobody heard about it.
Nobody knew is coming.
Will pull this up,
Jamie,
because the amount of energy.
So if we hit,
let's say New York,
what would have happened?
Everyone like Hiroshima,
bigger than here.
Here it is,
a media exposure over the Atlantic.
Like pull up the amount of power that
had had.
I had it on my,
um,
I had it on my twitter where it talked
about in relationship to a Hiroshima,
like how big of it was,
um,
due to do 500,000 tons of TNT.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's insane.
That was the one over Russia.
Oh,
this is what the one who thousand tons
of TNT.
Okay.
Oh,
the Russian one I remember from a few
years ago.
Yes.
But what's the,
what's the Atlantic Ocean one will pull
up the one that compared it to a pull up
the article that I had on my,
um,
on my twitter because it's,
it compared it to a,
a nuclear bomb.
Wow,
yeah,
well these are really common,
you know,
and I had this guy,
Randall Carlson on the podcast a few
times and he's dedicated his life to
paying attention to the signs of
asteroidal impacts all throughout
history and all throughout the world.
And astronomer.
Yeah,
and he believes that what's happened is
all throughout human history,
there's been these resets where people
accumulated a lot of data,
they learned a lot,
society move forward and then boom,
we got hit and then a lot of people died
and then they had to regroup,
start all over again.
And there's a lot of evidence in the
physical form.
This stuff called [inaudible],
I think it's called Triton night.
It's called new,
its nuclear glass,
they call it.
It's the same substance that they find
when they do nuclear tests in the desert
and stuff and they found it all
throughout Europe and Asia and they find
it when they do core samples between
like 10 and 12,000 years.
So it's exactly the same time as the end
of the ice age coincides with the end of
the ice age and with these these like
puzzling moments in civilization where
you have,
they'll find things like go Beckley
tappy,
these beautiful structures that are
really complex that are 14,000 years
old,
12,000 years old.
They're like,
who the fuck was building this stuff
back then when we thought people were
hunter gatherers and then right after
that,
boom,
we get hit by rocks.
Most people die,
a lot of people die and then they have
to regroup again.
And I think that that that's most likely
going to be the end of humanity just
like it was the end of the dinosaurs 65
million years ago.
It's much more common then we would then
we really would like to think about.
So definitely don't sweat it.
Don't sweat the small stuff.
Yeah.
There's no and mortality as far as this
dimension.
It's just,
it's not gonna happen.
So if you want to,
you want me to tell you a bit about the
evolutionary roots of religion,
how,
how you would study religion as an
evolutionist.
Okay.
You Ready?
Yeah.
So one argument is based on,
it's an adaptive argument,
right?
So the idea is if religion exists,
does that confer an adaptive advantage
to people?
And so there was some work done by a
good friend of Mine,
David Wilson and evolutionary biologist
where he argues using a group selection,
it's argument that that groups that are
religious out survive groups that are
not by virtue of them being more
communal,
more cohesive,
more abandoned.
So that argument is an adaptive argument
for why religion exists.
There's another argument by other
evolutionists that is based on an
exaltation arguing.
Have you ever heard that term except
acceptation.
What does that mean?
So that's a byproduct of evolution.
In other words,
it's something that evolved not because
itself,
it confers an adaptive advantage.
Rather it's piggybacking.
So for example,
the fact that your skeletal system is
the color that it is,
that itself is not adaptive.
It is a byproduct of other evolutionary
processes.
So from that perspective,
religion piggybacks on computational
systems in our brains that evolved for
other things.
You follow me,
for example,
coalitional thinking,
the idea of viewing the world as US
versus them,
blue team versus red team.
That is an innate part of our psychology
now.
Now religion piggybacks on that,
right?
It takes that computational system that
already exists in us and it,
it puts it on steroids,
right?
So you think about the Abrahamic
religions,
right?
Every one of them has us versus them.
They are the Jews,
the gentiles,
the believers,
the preferred,
right?
And so at agency detection,
detecting agency and things is something
that is innate to us.
Religion plays on that.
The agent becomes God,
and so that's an argument that was
proposed by Pascal where he's basically
saying that religion did not
specifically evolve because itself self,
it is adaptive,
but it piggybacks on other things that
have evolved.
And then a third way to study religion
is to just do a content analysis of the
the,
the narratives within religions.
So there's a great study done by a
Darwinian historian where she looked at
in the old testament how many women are
ascribed to a different male in the old
testament as a function of a status.
So the higher the status of the male,
the more sexual partners you had,
which is exactly what you would predict
from an evolutionary perspective.
High status to men confers reproductive
success.
So there are different ways that
evolution is.
And there are several other ways that
can study religion from an evolutionary
perspective.
That's pretty fascinating.
Well,
I also think that we've always,
as cultures have sort of tried to stay
alive and have tried to maintain order.
We've always tried to establish sets of
rules and boundaries and things and it
only makes sense that you would say,
hey,
you know,
there's a real reason why you can't kill
people.
And it's not because it makes everybody
upset.
It's because you're gonna go to hell,
right?
So listen,
you don't want to go to hell.
So don't kill people.
All these,
all these things that people have done
throughout history.
I mean,
if you look at religion on a global
scale,
there are some key components to almost
all religions and those seem to.
They seem to benefit order.
They seem to benefit culture and like
you were saying that the idea of people
living longer and being more successful
as a.
As a culture,
yeah,
we'll senses of community.
If you have a sense of community,
if you,
if you established community and
establish a bond between people and a
higher good or a higher reason to exist.
I'll give you another example.
A kosher laws actually have discussed
this in this book,
right?
So I try to offer a biological
explanation that is not rooted in
religious narratives for why kosher laws
would have evolved.
Right?
So think about the kosher edict that you
shouldn't eat shellfish.
Well,
so I did a lot of research when I was
writing the book on this issue.
It turns out that when you have
shellfish that is infected with a
particular pathogen,
red tie,
that's good.
That could kill you,
right?
Yes.
The one that is infected versus the one
that is uninformed,
not infected.
You can't really tell the difference
either through smell,
either through site,
so number one,
number two,
it's not as though the one that's coming
from an infected lives in mercury or
water,
so there was.
There is nothing that you could use in
terms of observational learning that can
offer you some statistical regularity of
if I do a,
b will happen once in a while.
Somebody eats a shellfish,
they dropped that.
I don't have a means.
I'm thinking as a Bronze Age guy running
around the Middle East to ever learn
from this mal addiction.
Therefore the only thing that I can do
is then say it is a edict from God.
Boom,
don't do it.
Of course.
So they are very,
very easy earthly biological reasons to
take food,
taboos,
religious taboos and demonstrate that
they have nothing.
But of course when I say this in a
classroom where there are people who
might otherwise be religious,
they see it.
Yet they can't completely follow you
because.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
because they have this doctrine in their
mind that is just the word of God will
also pigs eating pig.
Exactly.
I mean,
we all know that pigs contained trick of
gnosis and exactly bears as well,
you know,
it's supposed to eat bears.
There's a lot of reasons why kosher
living in,
you know,
a thousand,
5,000 years ago or whatever was really
smart,
smart way to go.
Have you.
Have you ever read.
I'm giving him here a,
a,
a thumbs up.
Maybe it'll help his book.
The Paleo manifesto by John Durant.
Uh,
no I haven't,
but John and I have been talking back
and forth on twitter and where he's
moving here.
So when he moves here,
he's dead to me.
You just said he's moving here.
I want to be in southern California.
Is that I now see my hair.
You were here for like three months,
right?
Weren't you here for a bunch of money
all the time.
But if you move here because I need a
professorship job here.
You're a smart guy selling books.
You're doing well.
But anyways,
and I think in his book he talks about,
I don't remember the exact number,
but he looked at the 613 commandments in
Jewish law and some outlandish number,
say something like 20 percent of them
deal with purity rituals.
And those purity rituals are ultimately
means very earthly means to try to
remove the possibility that you've been
exposed to dangerous pathogens.
Right?
So again,
you see how something that is cloaked
and the in the robe of religion is
ultimately solving a very basic earthly
biological problem.
Well also if you talk about
sexual
promiscuity,
right?
Controlling that controls sexually
transmitted diseases which like syphilis
and a lot of the really terminal ones
before they had medication for those
things,
they killed a lot of people.
A lot of people died from having sex,
which is just a ruthless,
cruel thank and you got to assume that
that's probably nature.
Trying to strike some sort of a balance,
right?
We don't want to think about it that
way,
but that's exists all throughout nature.
When animals become overpopulated,
all of a sudden they start developing
diseases and they fall off.
I mean that's the rabbit cycle,
if you're not aware of people that
aren't aware of rabbits go in a seven
year cycle,
so if you're around and you see a lot of
rabbits see rabbits all over the place
and then like three years later there's
no rabbits.
What happens is rabbits get to a high
population level and then they'll
develop a disease and they die off and
then there's only a few rabbits and then
it takes seven years until they reach
this peak and then they die off again in
a natural setting,
natural constant seven year cycle to
regulate the population of rabbits
because we all know that rabbits fuck
like rabbits and they,
they make a lot of babies and they don't
have that.
Unfortunately with pigs,
pigs are so hardy and so ruthless that
they.
They will have litters three,
four times a year.
I think a female pig can have a litter
as soon as like,
look this up,
Jamie,
but I want to say it's like within six
months,
within six months of being born she can
give birth,
which is crazy,
and they can just have piglets three
times a year and each time they do it
they'll have a bunch of them and they'll
just overtake places.
They got a problem in San Jose.
There was a news story on the other day
where these people were in their house
and the pigs were knocking over the
garbage can and eating up their lawn in
a normal residential neighborhood.
Like I mean a pretty crowded
neighborhood.
And these wild pigs are just roaming
through the streets now.
They're everywhere.
Have you.
Have you ever heard the term our case
selected?
Does that ring a bell?
Yes,
but I don't remember what it means.
So basically it's the idea that some
species produce many offspring with the
hope that very few will survive until
sexual maturity alligator frog,
right?
Many fish pigs,
right.
Versus a little on that scale,
they would be less so versus a elephant.
Humans where,
you know,
the gestational period,
the,
the length of parental investment that
is required before you reach sexual
maturity as much.
So it's either a lot of quantity hoping
that if you survive or much less
quantitative but heavily parental
investment and,
and just that right,
whether you are a species that is our
case,
like the,
the,
the reason for the arcade room doesn't
matter,
uh,
has a profound effect on the
evolutionary trajectory
of that species.
Right?
So thanks for example,
like a humans are a bike rental species,
right?
So even though you males invest
parentally less than females in the
human context,
we are really championed that.
I mean in the,
in the,
in the greater context of,
of mammals.
Human dads are just outlandish,
but there's no one like us,
nothing like us except for example,
penguins.
That's of course you're not mammals.
So,
and the human context then because we
are by parental species,
you would expect the evolution of a few
things.
One of which,
and I actually recently,
I discussed this in one of my lectures
because somebody asked that exact
question.
So the evolution of romantic love is if
you like a solution to this very
important problem,
which is you and I,
male,
female have to pair bond for a certain
period of time.
We have to be able to stand one another
for a sufficiently large enough period
of time to get our child to sexual
maturity and hence they are selection
pressures for us to evolve the aspect of
system that we call romantic love.
Uh,
so,
so this shows you how the pending on the
particular history of the species.
You get completely different.
Interesting trajectories,
Dennis.
Fascinating.
And it completely makes sense if you
think about it.
And there are certain animals like rats
or mice,
they're constantly being preyed upon.
They have to develop large litters.
Right?
Here's another one here at coping with
feral hogs.
Oh,
nice.
Five and six pigs per litter sounds of
approximately one point five liters per
year.
Yeah.
But when,
when can they get pregnant?
They get to the first litter when
they're 13 months of age.
It can be sexually mature at six months.
What's their life expectancy?
That's a good question.
I'd say 48 years of age,
that's if they don't get killed by a
cougar series.
Another one.
You Ready?
Check this out.
So if you don't know what sexual
dimorphism is.
Yes.
So right,
so humans are sexually dimorphic.
But take for example,
why don't you explain it to people that
don't know.
Sorry.
Yes.
So where,
where there is an innate sex difference.
Typically we talk about,
for example,
you're a sexist sex.
I realized,
you know,
sexual dimorphism is just a cultural,
it's a cultural construct.
It's not real.
And I like how you say it with the
affectations person.
I watch a woman in a video explained
that women are not inherently weaker
than men and just engage in less
strength based activities.
I've heard the exact same thing.
That's hilarious.
Well actually at [inaudible] even been
linked to the fact that little boys are
encouraged to play rough and tumble,
whereas little girls are dissuaded from
doing so and that's what sets them on
their trajectory.
So that Baba who plays center for
University of Nebraska can bench press
500 pounds.
It's completely social construction has
nothing to do with muscle mass.
Nothing to do with testosterone,
but anyways,
so going back to differences across
species,
so sexual dimorphism species are very
sexually
dimorphic.
See Elephant seals.
You have a male who's massive 44 times
the size of a female or a mountain
gorillas,
right?
So if you look at the extent to which
there is or isn't sexual dimorphism with
the species,
that itself perfectly predicts the
mating system within that species,
meaning if there is a huge sexual
dimorphism,
typically the males are bigger than the
females,
but sometimes you have sex reversal
species.
Then you have privilege in this meeting,
meaning what one male monopolizes sexual
access to many females,
and the reason why they develop that
size is because that's the combat that
they engage in where the winner then
gets the genetic lottery,
right?
On the other hand,
when you have species where the two
sexes are equal sized,
then you have typically monogamous
mating,
like in the case of some bird species,
but even there,
by the way,
even though they're supposed to be
monogamous,
once in a while,
they go behind the bush.
Genetic tests have shown,
well,
birds are really only male.
Penguins are a big one that people
bring.
Exactly.
Throwing monogamous for a year,
right?
But even even within what you consider
to be a monogamist window,
there are some tests that show that once
in a while we do go behind the bushes,
that it's behind.
That Bush did not win the game.
I tried to,
once in a while,
uh,
use my evolutionary stuff on my wife to
explain why it might be okay to do this.
She hasn't really bought into the whole
thing.
Read more,
get her head out of the bushes.
Exactly sand wherever.
By the way,
incidentally,
this whole idea of taking an
evolutionary explanation and then people
thinking that that then justifies or
condones the behavior as a classic
reason why people hate evolutionary
psychology,
right?
So if you explain,
you know,
here's a,
here's an evolutionary explanation for
rape,
here's an evolution explanation for wild
child abuse happens.
If there's a step parent in the family,
here's why people might have difficulty
staying true to their monogamous unions,
then people will get very upset at you
because they somehow conflate the fact
that you are explaining the phenomenon
using science as meaning that you are
saying it clears your moral judgment and
of course it doesn't,
but that's one of the places where
people get really upset at you and we'll
send you hate mail in that moral
judgment is also cultural,
which gets really strange when you look
at certain religions like the Mormons,
right?
The whole reason why the Mormons a setup
this compound in Mexico while they moved
to Mexico,
is when polygamy was made illegal in the
United States.
Will we're just going to go to Mexico.
And that's where Mitt Romney's family
came around.
Which is really bizarre.
Isn't it amazing how whenever there are
these,
uh,
polygynous rulings from God,
it's always that.
It's one man with multiple women.
It's never been a polyandrous thing.
It's never been the other way around.
Don't want to get a gang bang.
I didn't want a bunch of dudes.
You know,
there is one place in the world where
there is polyandry.
Do you know where it is?
Somewhere?
That sucks.
It's called Tibetan.
Polyandry told you it's safe.
It's fraternal to Beth and polyandry.
Eternal.
Yeah.
Which means b means brothers and
sisters.
No meaning at a frat together,
meaning that the woman who is being
shared across many men,
those men are brothers.
That's crazy.
But here's the evolutionary explanation,
right?
Imagine where you have a system for
whatever reason,
we're not every man could be mated.
That's not a good thing because you have
a lot of men who are going to be
sexually frustrated,
right?
China,
Exactly.
You know,
so therefore by creating a system where,
okay,
not everybody could be guaranteed that
their reproductive fitness is going to
be assured,
but at least they're kin selection will
be assured.
Meaning what?
I share half of my genes on average from
my brother.
So either I will impregnate the woman,
in which case great.
Or my brother will impregnate her,
in which case I'm still indirectly not
through direct reproductive fitness,
but through kin selection,
I'm still extending my jeans.
So even in cases where men share a
woman,
it has to be in the context of all in
the family.
Whoa,
I'm blowing your mind.
That's,
that's an intense thing and that's.
That must be just a reaction to the fact
that there is much more men than there
are women.
And why would that be?
Why are there more men than there?
So sometimes it could be.
That's called by the way and operational
sex ratio.
If there are imbalances between males
and females within a particular niche,
sometimes it could be because of certain
inheritance structures where it's only
the eldest who can have enough money
through inheritance so the other guys
can't really afford a what.
So there are all sorts of institutional
reasons beyond sex,
racial reasons where some men may
otherwise be out of the mating market
and we know that societies were.
A lot of men are sitting around sexually
frustrated is not going to be societies
that are conducive to quiet and so
therefore.
So therefore,
even in the context where you have
something like polyandry,
which is something that typically
evolutionary speaking,
you wouldn't expect.
When it arises,
it arises as a response to a real
evolutionary problem,
so,
so every,
I mean most things that you could think
of ultimately have some evolutionary
expansion to them and that's why I fell
in love with evolution because the
explanatory power that is afforded once
you have that key to understand things
via evolutionary thinking,
it becomes incredibly powerful and once
the parameters and the variables change,
the behavior changes to adapt to those
parameters.
Variables.
Exactly right.
A perfect example that is fighter
pilots,
fighter pilots are classically wife
swappers.
Is that true?
Yeah.
There's a lot of that goes on in those
communities because these people
are swingers,
you mean?
Yeah,
well sort of.
Yeah.
Well it's.
You know what it is.
They know that they're probably going to
die and if they love their wife,
they want someone else to love their
wife as much as they do.
And the idea is that if they all just
shit like life is,
it's different.
It's much more fleeting.
It's much more fragile than it is in the
world of the Accountant,
you know?
So I think it makes sense that that's
very prevalent in those communities.
So the,
the,
if you like,
the sexual risk taking is a form of
insurance policy.
Say it like if you,
uh,
you,
you were married and Jamie was married
and you were both fighter pilots and uh,
you both would do missions together,
like an intense bond between you guys
and you know,
you would just swap wives who would just
say,
look,
you know,
the idea is like if you die,
if you get shot down and you die,
you know,
you want your wife to be taken care of
by someone who loves her.
Right?
As long as they had a smaller penis in
me,
Jamie's got a hog tell you it's got a
hard on the kid.
But by going,
going good luck with that.
Going back to,
by the way,
I'll send you the link to the global,
a penis sizes around the world and I'll
just point you to where Lebanon scores
on that.
Whereas how's it go?
Pretty good.
Top is it,
is it like where people are like,
we're,
there's more danger,
dicks or bigger?
I've never heard that this is the first
time,
well isn't been like so danger.
One of the most dangerous places,
right?
They danger and in terms of violence and
crime and like,
look,
if you classically,
let's all,
let's put away all pretenses of racism.
Right?
Back.
Black guys supposedly have the biggest
dicks.
Right?
Why is that?
Do they have um,
more athleticism too.
That's a lot of things that people
connect to it.
So drone system scientifically,
has that been absolutely proven?
You know it.
And I let it go.
I know that anecdotally we hear that.
You're like,
no,
no Lebanese.
If you just check it's a Lebanese people
know mean it's always know it's a
stereotype,
but I truly don't know whether it's
scientists.
I mean there's certain stereotypes that
are just,
there's a reason there and that's a,
that's one that is acceptable when you
talk about black people.
Yeah.
Because it's got the venture that it's
complementary.
Right,
right.
Uh,
I'll tell you a great story about racial
differences.
So in 1995,
I think it was 1995,
[inaudible] 96.
I'm giving a talk.
So this is shortly after my phd,
I just started as a young assistant
professor.
I'm giving a talk at this big
international psychology conference and
is maybe a thousand 500 people in this
room and that that's quite a big size
for academic conference and there's a
real buzz in the room as if there's
tension and I'm not exactly sure why.
They're certainly not 10 set me at that
point.
I was just a young guy.
Nobody knew who the hell I was
immediately before I get up to present.
So the guy who was immediately before me
is a gentleman by the name of Phillip
Rushton.
Have you ever know,
you know him?
Phil oppression is a,
uh,
was he recently passed away.
He was a Canadian based psychologist who
is probably the preeminent psychologist
who studied racial differences and
offered evolutionary explanations for
why these racial differences might
exist.
And most notably he had looked at a
suppose that racial differences,
racial differences in intelligence using
a postmortem cranial size.
Right.
So the fact is that if the carrying
capacity cavities bigger or smaller than
you assume that that means the person
from this race is more intelligent than
that race,
this controversial research.
Very,
very spicy research.
So anyways,
so this guy gets up to present his stuff
and he starts putting up slides of black
male,
black female,
white male,
white female,
and you see the,
I mean the crowd is like,
you know,
sharpening their knives to lynch the sky
and I have to get up and present right
after him and I'm thinking that just by
proxy,
just by,
by being close to him,
I'm going to get killed.
Now the good news is that immediately
after he finished his presentation,
out of the 1,500 people who were there,
about 1000,
425 left the room to find him really.
So.
So there was nearly no one left to
listen to my talk.
And that was one of the few times where
I was actually very pleased to have very
few people listening to me.
So they left the room.
And what do they do that I think they
wanted to sort of,
uh,
you know,
challenge him and confront him and so
on.
Does when a guy does a speech like that,
does he allow a question?
Answer period is very,
very good question.
So usually you would leave depending on
the size of the.
I mean let's say you have 25 minutes,
so you might do 20 minutes leaving five
minutes for q and a,
he went to the last second so that there
was no opportunity for questions and
then he sort of was whisked out.
Uh,
and so I was really,
really pleased that almost nobody stayed
from my talk.
What's interesting about that is there a
certain truths that you're not allowed
to explore and you're not allowed to
explore the possibility that some human
beings may be not as intelligent as
other human beings on an individual
level or as a group level.
What I was going to.
Oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
As on an individual level,
we accept that,
but on a group level we're not willing
to on an individual level,
at the individual level,
even while they're retarded.
I,
well that's why it's proof,
but,
but it's interesting that like there's
certain genetic variables that will
accept that are a product of the
environment in which these people
develop.
Like for instance,
inuits are much more adapted to cold.
Their hands don't get numb.
They don't get frostbite nearly as easy.
They can operate.
They have been much better circulation
in cold weather and their hands and
their feet and let's,
because they've been living up there for
generation after generation there.
There's certain
things that we don't accept though and
one of the big ones is intelligence.
We don't accept that some people could
live in a soft world where things are
easy and they develop like a slow,
lazy mind.
Whereas some people develop in a very
tricky world with this constant
innovation going on and they develop a
sharper mind.
You know,
we,
we were,
we resist that because we don't want
anyone thinking that they're dumber than
other people.
Right.
Well,
um,
the,
the point though is that I'm not sure
that anybody has offered compelling
explanation for why they would be
selection pressures in environment a
versus environment,
be for there to be greater intelligence.
So I think there is some evidence that,
especially European Jews who have more
Nobel prize awards than anyone else.
Why do you have to dis me by saying
European Jews?
Why don't you answer the Arab Jews?
Well,
it's true though.
It's just because you're a very
intelligent man,
obviously,
but I'm neither your,
well,
I'm sort of European,
Italian.
Um,
you know,
there's something fascinating about that
to me.
And I wonder if that's cultural.
I wonder if that's educational.
I mean,
what,
what is that?
So,
so I can certainly definitively point to
the cultural elements,
like the genetic element is,
is debatable,
right?
Uh,
and so it's neither,
yes or no,
it's unclear.
But the cultural element that I'll share
with you a personal anecdote,
I don't,
I don't think I've ever shared it on the
show before or if I have,
it's still worth repeating.
Uh,
after I finished my Mba.
I mean,
I knew I was going to go on and do my
phd and become a professor,
but at one point I had a brother who
lives in southern California.
It was a very successful businessman and
I was coming out here to see whether I
want it to go and do my phd at Uc
Irvine,
uh,
versus other schools where I had been
accepted.
And he said,
hey,
you know what,
why don't you put on the proverbial
sooth and maybe work with me for a few
years before you go on to get your phd.
It might be a nice thing for you to get
some work experience outside of
academia.
I wasn't really entertaining it.
Buy My mother a herd of this
possibility.
And so when I went back to Montreal,
she,
she took me aside to one of the rooms
and very,
very concerned.
She said to me,
remember if you,
if you don't go on to get your phd,
I mean,
do you want people to remember you as
somebody who's dropped out of school?
So from her perspective,
from the standards that we're expected,
somebody who had,
you know,
I've got an Undergrad in mathematics and
computer science and I've gotten an MBA.
Uh,
if I stopped at that point,
I will drop out.
I'm a dropout from school.
I have an MBA from a top school right
now.
Of course I didn't do a phd from my
parents' approval,
but it just gives you the sense of the
type of expectations.
Then the,
the,
the imparting of love for learning,
for knowledge,
for wisdom and achievement and
achievement that is inbred in you from
the minute you come out of the womb.
So whether there is a genetic component
or not,
I don't know,
but I can certainly say that the
component is very alluring
cultural components.
It exists very strongly in the Korean
community.
It was a good buddy of mine when I was a
kid who's Korean,
who was on the US national taekwondo
team while he was in his residency as a
doctor.
I mean,
he was a fucking animal.
This kid,
I mean,
he,
I've never met anybody who worked
harder.
He slept like three or four hours a
night.
He was always exhausted.
Every time you look at me,
a giant bags under his eyes and he
couldn't possibly have physically worked
harder than he did.
I mean,
did.
He did everything he possibly could.
One the US national title went on to
compete in international competitions
all while he was going to medical school
instead of a madness.
And the way he described it to me,
you know,
it was,
it was more of a prison.
The way he described it,
he was just burdened.
He was always tired and he,
it was just expected of him.
He was really upset by it.
Yeah.
It's not quite as.
I wouldn't,
I don't know what the right term is.
Autocratic or dictatorial.
I think it's more a,
the Baiting,
right?
I mean,
thinking about,
for example,
the Talmudic tradition,
when you sit down and you debate,
you discuss you the bay.
So there's this,
there's this endless inculcation of the
pursuit of knowledge just for the sake
of knowledge that is endemic to all
Jewish homes.
Uh,
and to,
to the extent that some of my family
members did not have that particular
orientation,
frankly,
I didn't get along with them as well
because I have some family members who
are quite mercantile in their approach.
They just care about money and I was
always maybe to a fault,
somebody who cared more about ideas than
I did about money.
What could be a fault?
How could there be a fault there and,
and,
and not pursuing it.
Well in the sense,
for example,
that I'm not a careerist in other words,
I do things out of purity.
I don't strategize.
I don't.
Sounds like an awesome dude.
Well,
thank you.
All right,
well,
I'll give you an example.
I'll give you a very concrete example,
right?
You were asking earlier,
you know,
well,
why don't you get a job here?
Well,
listen,
by me taking very open positions on
topics that are quote politically
incorrect,
I'm not being a careerist.
If I would shut my mouth about all
these,
these issues,
maybe some university that might
otherwise be very impressed with my
scientific dossier might say,
Hey,
this is,
this guy's good.
But if he's a shitster,
if he appears on Joe Rogan and makes fun
of trigger warnings and talks about
Islam,
well he's a bit of a loose cannon.
This is why I disagree.
The amount of input that you can have on
a culture based out of teaching a
classroom of 100 people or more whatever
it is in comparison to what you're doing
already on your youtube videos.
Thank you.
It's.
It's phenomenal.
The reach that you have right now.
I'm going to send this to some of the
universities that are supposed to hire
me.
Well,
they don't look.
They're all in the past.
These people did understand what's going
on right now.
Right now.
There's.
There's a podcast that you're doing
right now
that will be heard and watched by more
than a million people for sure.
Without a doubt.
Not only that,
it'll exist in perpetuity as long as we
have digital content,
it'll exist.
So there's people listening to this
right now,
50 years from now,
100 years from now,
if they're still alive,
if there's still a world to live in 100
years now people are going to be living
in listening to this.
You are literally,
you know,
music to my ears what you're saying
because I just had this conversation
recently where I was talking to a
university about the importance actually
to,
to a dean when I was talking about the
importance of how do we judge academics.
I mean academics are meme creators,
right?
We create memes through our science,
but we're also a meme propagators now.
To me,
one of the highlights of coming to
southern California and that's saying a
lot,
given how much I love southern
California,
is to appear on your show because I know
that the platform that you have,
it'll take me 16,000 years to be able to
even come close to achieving that type
of.
And it's not because of a narcissist
thing.
I want to be famous because ultimately
I'm about spreading ideas and that's
exactly what you said.
I mean a million people are going to
listen to,
so if I can get one percent of that
million to be interested in evolutionary
theory after what we've discussed,
how does that compare to having 25
students in my classroom,
but most universities,
you're exactly right.
Haven't caught up with the times.
No one has the university itself.
Okay.
This is not the only way you can learn
these ideas,
that the only way to get an education is
to get a degree.
To go to sit in class,
to do all the work.
The teacher prescribes all this stuff
that you have to turn in and all the
papers that you have to do.
That's not the only way to get an
education.
That's nonsense.
This is a human construct and we're
living in a world where that doesn't
make much sense anymore.
You're gonna have in the future,
a primary education is going to be
online.
It's without a doubt.
Why travel somewhere white go somewhere.
Especially when you dealing with all
these fucking assholes in these campuses
that are instituting all these
ridiculous rules of social behavior and
all these social misfits that want to
level the playing field and all this
nonsense that's going on.
That's really it.
It stifles a lot of open discussion.
It stifles a lot of,
of exchanges of information because of
these ideas.
These people have that these are these
rigid ideas that cannot be breached.
I think we're living in a world now
where you have instant access to
information to go to a physical place to
learn.
Seems to me to be kind of archaic.
It's kind of retro isn't ours.
Just recently asked.
Maybe I shouldn't be commenting
publicly,
but I go ahead and do it.
Uh,
there's a company called great courses.
Have you heard of it?
Yeah.
They were a sponsor of the podcast in
the beginning.
No kidding.
Yeah.
I have one of them at home on
psychology,
so I was honored to be asked to.
It hasn't yet.
We haven't signed a contract.
They're still looking into it,
but the mere fact that they
contacted me as one of the perspective
people to put together a course for
them,
a great courses course on evolutionary
psychology and so awesome.
Thank you.
So,
I mean,
imagine the number of people that I can
potentially reach by putting together
that course.
Look,
there's this guy.
You should check him out.
Robert Sapolsky or you know,
very well known.
Yeah,
from Stanford.
I'm not loving you more and more by the
second.
I work on toxoplasmosis.
I've been studying him for years.
Look at this stuff on baboons.
Isn't it mind going,
oh my God.
So I need to spend like months every
year in Africa.
Youtube clips.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of that.
So anyway,
so I wrote to him,
by the way,
maybe I shouldn't be advertising a
failure,
but it's okay.
So I wrote to him because I really
wanted him on my show and he was very
gracious.
He responded right away,
said,
look,
I'd love to.
So on.
I'm just,
I'm working on two books.
I'm shutting down everything.
I'm saying no to everybody.
Maybe some point in the future,
which of course I completely understand,
but you know,
look at this guy.
I mean you go to his youtube,
whatever,
900,000 views,
one point,
1 million of a lecture that typically
would have been viewed by 80 people.
Right?
I Bet I sent a couple of hundred
thousand people to those things.
Just no kidding.
Big Fan of that guy been sending people
to is his videos and his lectures for
years.
So let's talk about what are the
findings from his drone to do that.
Sure.
So he's got research,
because you mentioned baboons showing
that in a,
in a,
in a sort of a hierarchical society of
baboons,
the lower ranked baboons will have
higher cortisol levels,
will have more stress hormones.
While you intuitively you might think
the opposite.
You might think that the higher the rank
of the baboon,
the more stressed he is because he's.
He asked to defend against all the other
dangers and maintain his position and so
on.
So people took this exact study and
applied it in an organizational context
where they looked at an organizational
hierarchy and took cortisol levels of
people in a big organization.
I think it was a the public health
system in Britain,
the higher the rank of the employee,
the lower his or her cortisol level and
the argument.
So you might say,
well,
why would that be?
Wouldn't the person who is higher rank
be more stressed?
I mean a CEO has to have more stress
than,
you know,
the janitor.
And one of the arguments at least that
they proposed was the idea of freedom.
The guy who was at the lowest rung of
the hierarchy has to be told when he
could go and relieve himself with his
bodily functions.
Right?
I mean,
his,
the amount of free destiny that he has
in his daily life is very limited.
Whereas at least the CEO,
even though he's working very hard,
he's more master of his,
uh,
of his daily life.
So for example,
I work all the time.
I can work 10,
12,
15,
18 hour days,
but yet I still am.
I feel like I'm always free because
there's
nobody who's telling me what to do with
when at any time and apparently just
that has a profound effect on your
cortisol levels and the origins of that
whole study were originally due to
Polsky's work with baboons.
If I believe,
if I'm correct,
well you know that the finding is
mirrored in a special ops guys versus
versus enlisted men versus your average
soldier.
Like one of the big issues that people
have today is ptsd and one of the
factors in ptsd is people who are
waiting for things to happen versus
people who are making things happen.
Whereas seals,
rangers,
people that they send in to go and kick
ass and take names.
Those guys have way less stress,
which is kind of crazy.
Way less incidences of PTSD and you
know,
obviously still tremendously stressful
and still a lot of instances of ptsd but
less.
And the more guys that I talked to that
have served will tell you that the
reason is that they're active and that
they're.
They're proactive.
They're the ones who are moving in and
doing these things and they're going
after these bad guys and hunting them
down essentially.
Whereas the other people are sitting
around the base worrying they're going
to get attacked or you know,
saying on their post or driving a car,
worrying they're going to hit an IED.
Very interesting.
So let's,
let's propose it.
And another hypothesis was maybe
somebody who's a graduate student might
test a coaches versus players.
So based on your logic of the findings
that you just said,
the coach should probably have much
higher cortisol levels because he writes
out of his control and that's why you
see them on the sidelines going freaking
out,
going crazy because you really can't
affect much influence on the game.
I mean you can add the margins that in
terms of the strategies and so on.
But the guys that are in the battle,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I was a competitive soccer player and of
course you are not the few minutes
before you've got butterflies.
Once you're in the thick of things,
you're not stressed,
you're focused.
I mean,
you're in the flow,
but the coaches,
they're the ones who are about to have a
heart attack,
so I thank you.
The intestine,
that is probably also a big factor why
it's so difficult to beat a champion in,
in combat sports because the champion is
the one who's in control and the
champion is one has been dominating.
He has fear and intimidation on his side
and therefore he has less stress.
Right?
He's been,
I mean,
it's going to have stress no matter what
if you're entering into a fight,
but the person who's trying to overcome
the psychological barrier that is the
champion in front of them,
like this is big.
There's a persona that's attached to
like a good example is like Mike Tyson,
when he was in his prime,
nobody wanted to believe that he can be
beaten and men would lose before they
ever got into the ring that he.
Buster Douglas case.
Yeah.
You did.
So have you ever seen the study,
and I don't know if we've mentioned it
here before,
uh,
I think it was published in the journal
called a motion where they looked at,
I think it was mma fighters,
whether they smiled or not before the
contest.
Have you seen this before?
No.
Okay.
You just send me a private message and
I'll look for it.
I can't remember the exact details,
but there was some nonverbal cues that
were studied prior to a fight that if,
if,
if I remember the study correctly,
were highly predictive of the eventual
outcome.
Wow.
That's fast.
And is that cool?
Well,
I bet they're highly predictive of the
amount of focus at the fighters entering
to the octagon with here he goes,
smiles are for losers.
I love how you come up.
Studies show that MMA fighters who smile
before fights don't do well.
Well,
this is at a way in which I doubt you
could really tell and that was published
that what they're saying,
the pre-fight stare down.
Okay.
So the preflight steered on that.
Well,
that makes sense because if you're
smiling,
it,
it most likely means that you're not
really in the game.
Right.
As expected,
smile intensity predicted both the
outcomes of fights as well as the more
detailed measures of inflight hostility.
Interestingly,
the smiles predicted both reduced
hostility from the smiler as well as
increased hostility from his opponent.
In other words,
it seemed that both fighters were
attuned to the information being
communicated in the preflight smile.
These results held even when controlling
for existing differences in skill.
I e the betting odds of the fight and
strength,
height and weight though don't go.
Don't go drastically altering your
gambling strategy just yet.
The betting lines still did a better job
overall in predicting fights compared to
just smile intensity.
Yeah.
Huh.
Have you.
Have we talked here about a ratio?
Yes.
No,
but I,
I've,
I know what you're talking about.
They're like the size of fingers at one
of the,
uh,
the,
the length of a digital always.
I've actually,
I think I've thought about at some point
either asking you or my nephew to get
access to mma fighters to take some
measures that capture how androgen highs
they are,
how much exposure to testosterone at
whether it be,
for example,
through certain facial features or
through A.
Well,
they're two d,
four d ratio,
which is a measure of how much
testosterone you've been exposed to in
utero.
And so I actually have a study right now
with one of my graduate students without
a Rumiyah,
uh,
where we're looking at the links between
testosterone and extreme sports using
the exact same idea.
And so,
um,
of course an obvious hypothesis might be
that on average and then they fighters
compared to a control,
normal population,
non non fighters,
uh,
will be more androgens.
You would think that that has to be
true,
right?
I don't know.
Okay.
Because I would wonder what are the,
I would say maybe probably successful
ones I see we've moderated by whether
they are,
what their trajectory in their career
was.
I think there are a lot of people who
enter into mixed martial arts or martial
arts in general because they recognize
there's a lot of benefit in trying
to overcome extreme challenges and that
they're attracted to these things
because they get addicted to the rush,
the adrenaline rush of a challenge and
it's very few challenges that are
intense as one on one competition with
another person.
Um,
and I think there's a lot of people who
gravitate towards those,
not necessarily even,
it seems counterintuitive,
but you would think that they would be
the most violent people or the most
angry people and they're doing that
because they want to dominate.
Well,
mixed martial arts is different in a lot
of ways,
first of all,
because in boxing,
a lot of times you're seeing people that
are searching for a way out there
searching for a way out of poverty.
They're searching for a way out of bad
neighborhoods and crime and they do so
through fighting.
It's a classic,
it's a classic trope,
but I think there's something going on
with MMA fighters.
It's very different in that martial arts
seem to be something that costs money
and so to join these classes and get
proficient,
you have to be able to afford them.
And so you're getting people that enter
into martial arts from two different
venues,
right?
You get wrestlers who classically get it
from school that you get it from high
school.
Rico,
Roman wrestlers,
you mean freestyle or Greco Roman,
you know,
depending on.
It doesn't matter.
There's,
there's successful examples of both.
And wrestling is probably one of the
most important skills to have,
if not the most important in mma because
the fighter can dictate where the fight
takes place.
If a really strong wrestler takes you
down,
he can control you were as if you're a
really good kick boxer.
Your kickboxing can't really be
effective.
Someone can take you down at will.
So there's,
there's that,
there's the wrestling which they get in
college and they get in high school in
which is,
you know,
at least fairly free college if they
have a scholarship and get it for free.
Um,
but martial arts,
like Jujitsu and kickboxing and things
along those lines,
taekwondo,
karate,
traditional martial arts,
it costs money to take those things.
Right?
So you're seeing a lot of very educated
people that are getting into mma.
There's a lot of MMA fighters that are
extremely articulate.
Isn't there a guy who was a biology
teacher,
math teacher,
rich Franklin math teacher who was a
former champion.
Yeah,
he was UFC champion,
very smart guy,
very smart guy.
And there's a lot of other very,
very intelligent guys speak multiple
languages,
you know,
really brilliant people.
Um,
so you get a different style of fighter,
you know,
I think there's people out there that
are fighting because they were abused as
a child.
They were bullied and then they have
this anger inside of them and they want
to express it.
So you get a lot of that,
but you also get people that just,
you know,
they're just tough.
It's just tough and they want to
overcome challenges and they,
they get some sort of benefit out of
these extreme challenges.
So I would,
I would wonder,
I would wonder what the results of that
would be.
What about this,
this,
I think this is probably an obvious
hypothesis,
but do you think that if we,
if one were to a
salivary assays to measure testosterone
levels,
pre-fight post fight and post fight,
you're looking at the winner and the
loser,
clearly the testosterone scores would
assort along whether I won or lost exam
will also dependent upon how much brain
damage they acquire during the fight.
That has a pretty significant effect on
your pituitary gland.
Primarily I had,
by the way,
uh,
since you're a standup professional
stand up comedian,
one of my former students of postdoc who
had,
I think I'm going to mention,
he,
he studied the evolutionary roots of
humor.
And so one of the things that we wanted
to study when he was doing his post doc
with me,
but then he ended up leaving after a
year to take a position anyways,
uh,
was to use the Montreal just for laughs
festivals to study that.
The Stasi responses of Comedians,
uh,
you know,
prior to getting on stage.
And then after finishing and to see
whether their testosterone response
would be moderated by whether
objectively speaking it was a successful
set or not.
Right.
I mean sometimes you get up and you just
killed the house.
Other Times it's.
It's dead silence.
So will my endocrinological system
response track that reality.
And so that's something that I still
hopefully we'll test with some future
students.
What do you think?
You think that's a viable?
Definitely.
I think with bombing especially,
it comes down.
Yeah,
definitely.
It's a horrible feeling.
I can't imagine there would be any
benefit to bombing.
Right?
Other than maybe your testosterone would
spike because you need the energy to run
away from them.
Do you?
Let's say when you,
when you're like you are doing a show
and you feel as though it's not going
well.
Are you ever able to redirect the ship
or do you.
Or is there a point where there's no
return?
I'm going to suck today.
It's just not working.
I'm not connecting.
There's both.
There's,
there's definitely times where you're
not getting out of the hole.
You know,
you can dig yourself into a hole that
you can't get out of it.
What determines that?
Is it that your delivery that day is not
working or is it there's something
endemic to the crowd that for whatever
reason,
they're just not digging your style.
It's all the above.
There's a.
It could be your delivery,
it could be your subject matter.
It could be an event,
something that went on with the
audience.
It could be the way you are reacting to
them that you chose a path that was
ineffective.
It could be making fun of them,
but that got them to get more on you.
It could certainly be that.
It could cause a lot of variables
involved in whether or not you go down
with the ship,
but also it could be that you didn't
address it.
You know,
sometimes things are going bad and a guy
will address that.
It's going bad and they pulled
themselves out of it and then it becomes
great again.
I've seen that.
I've done that.
I've had like bad moments.
We address that bad moment and things
snap back or you,
you know,
you just,
you reassess your approach.
It does a lot of variables involved in
standup comedy,
but ultimately what's going on.
I've tried to explain this and I've gone
over this with many,
many comedian friends of mine and we all
seem to agree on this.
So there's a moment when things are
going really well with the audience is
laughing and you're in the zone and
you're delivering your jokes that you
prepared for a long time.
Everything's done right.
And it's a lot of great timing and
everything.
It's a,
it's a mass hypnosis.
It's like when I watch a really funny
comedian firewatch a bill burr for say,
um,
when,
when he's on stage and he's killing and
I'm watching and I'm laughing my ass
off,
what I am doing is allowing him to think
for me.
Right?
So I'm allowing him to,
you know,
if he's talking about having a female
president or something like that,
he's going through his thought process
of what it would be like Bubba,
Bubba,
and as he's going through it,
I am.
I'm not really doing any calculations,
I'm allowing him to do all those
calculations.
I'm allowing him to take up all of my
thought process with his sentences and
the the,
the,
the images that he's depicting and
that's what makes it really funny and
the whole audience,
we're all in it together,
so there's this community effect of this
group hypnosis,
so we're all laughing because we're all
on the same page and we're all like
these thoughts that he's saying are so
funny and we're all going along with it,
but when someone's bad or when the joke
doesn't work,
then everybody's like,
Oh,
Christ,
oh no,
this isn't working.
Oh No.
And you'll look around and see everybody
else's uncomfortable and then you see
he's uncomfortable and I'm like,
oh Jesus,
he's,
he's bombing right now.
And when someone's bombing,
then you're forced to completely out of
the spell and now you have to do all
these calculations.
You have to think,
you have to do all this,
all this consideration,
considerations going on.
There's a lot happening that wouldn't be
happening if a guy was just killing,
but someone's killing.
It's effortless to watch.
Just laughing it off and then you leave.
You feel great.
So it's when it goes bad,
it's uncomfortable for everybody.
It's uncomfortable for the audience.
It's uncomfortable for the comedian.
It's just because you're forced to
consider his process,
his failures or her failures and her bad
jokes or all those things.
Do you think there are certain elements
of humor?
I mean clearly they are culture specific
manifestations of you are maybe physical
comedy is more appreciated and culture,
Asian culture be,
but are there specific umer mechanisms
that are not mechanism but you know,
whatever bueller content that would be
universally successful?
No.
Oh,
so you think it's always culture
dependent,
culture dependent,
taste dependent.
There's certain styles of humor that
some people really enjoy and other
people hate.
You know,
some people like all tumor,
which is like keep the mic in the stand,
don't move dead.
Pan Delivery,
put very little effort forth.
Some people like that.
That's what they prefer.
The balding guy with the curly hair,
balding guy with the curly found like 20
years ago.
He speaks with a very low steven,
right?
Yeah.
Well he's an absurdist.
What does that all absurd?
Yeah,
he's like a used to work at a fire
hydrant factory.
Couldn't park anywhere near the place.
You know,
it's like,
that's,
that's the thing,
right,
you know,
is that kind of comedy.
It's like,
it's all like really bizarre and I
observed one liners.
Um,
so that's not all that's just really
funny and original and all it is a lot
of times really bad,
you know,
unfortunately.
And it really,
super supportive crowds that gather
together,
it's almost like they got kicked out of
the cool playground so they made their
own playground and there's a comedy
festival that's going on right now are
supposed to be going on some somewhere
in New York where somebody sent me this
thing and I looked at it for a couple of
seconds.
I have throw it away.
I just like,
I can't,
I can't even get into this where they're
charging different amounts for different
access to people who are white males.
They,
they want to have as few white males as
possible,
so they want to make it as diverse as
possible.
So they're opening it up to people of
color,
Lbgtq x,
Y,
Z,
and,
and this is like,
this is their solution.
Their solution is to not just have the
funniest people that they think are
there regardless of race,
color,
creed,
ethnicity.
Nope.
Exclude the white man and token white
bearded men is one of the things that
they discussed.
And by the way,
the people that run the group were all
women.
So hilarious.
I mean,
if you want to run a festival,
you should be able to do whatever the
fuck you want,
but the idea that you want to run an art
festival,
but you want to exclude certain people
like pick the best ones.
How about pick the best ones,
the best ones.
Turn out to be white men with beards.
Go with that information and try to
figure out why that's the case.
So from that perspective,
are we to assume that I now know what
your position is on affirmative action?
Well,
my position on affirmative action is,
um,
I think it has good intentions.
I think the idea is to try to stop
racism.
However,
if you're getting someone in there,
they become a firefighter,
but they're less physically fit and less
intelligent than someone who could have
gotten the job,
but unfortunately the,
the other guy was from Croatian descent,
you know,
and you know,
he looks like a white man who is
privileged,
you know,
but meanwhile this guy came from a
family of very poor immigrants who
struggled and scratched and scraped and,
you know,
people could look at him as the
oppressor,
which is fucking preposterous.
You know,
there's a lot of that going on.
Yeah.
And,
um,
I think that's ridiculous.
So I think that.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
I think this idea of people who are all
have a certain amount of melanin in
their skin that they should get a job
versus people who don't have melanin in
their skin.
That's stupid,
right?
I think we should address the core
problem,
which is why,
why is it harder for people who grow up
in African American communities or
Mexican American communities?
Why is it harder for them to get a
better education?
Why is it harder for them to succeed?
Why is it hard for them to resist crime?
Why are they in involved in these
impoverished areas?
And how do we fix that?
So,
you know what Larry,
and we bounced that,
you know who larry elder's to sage,
have you ever had them on the show?
But I will.
He's,
he and I had been going back and forth
through twitter.
Uh,
of course,
you know what his answer would be.
So he's an African American.
He's also,
let's say,
what is the reason for all of the things
that you said,
why this,
why that father absence he at now,
I don't know whether he is a overusing
that,
uh,
that causal factor,
but he certainly seems to be quoting a
lot of data that suggests that many of
these sort of delirious downstream
effects are due to nothing more than
father absence.
Solve that problem and many of these
issues would go away.
Well,
I think that's a little simplistic
because your dad's a fucking piece of
shit and lives in your house,
you've got a real problem,
right?
You know,
I don't think that's necessarily the
only way to do it.
Um,
and I think you can't just blame,
I think one of the things that we were
talking about earlier that I think is
really important is that cultures become
patterns and patterns repeat and these
patterns that these people are born
into,
it's not their choice.
And we recognize it as someone who
wasn't born in that pattern.
You look at a bad pattern of someone
being born say,
like in Baltimore and extremely
impoverished community is filled with
crime and gang violence and you go,
God,
how do we,
how does this get corrected?
How do we.
I had Michael Wood on who's an
interesting guy who was a former cop in
Baltimore and really,
really interesting dude and I think he's
trying to run for like he's trying to be
a police commissioner.
CHICAGO,
right?
I applied for it and you know,
I think he would be a great person for
that job.
Um,
he's got a lot of information and a lot
of really,
he's very smart,
right?
Law Common Sense when it comes to this.
But one of the things that Michael Wood
was talking about when he was on the
podcast was that they had found a,
I guess a directive from the 19
seventies when they were going through
the archives and all the shit that they
have in Baltimore.
The police director from the 19
seventies was exactly the same as what
he was dealing with in the two thousands
as far as the neighborhoods that had
drugs and neighborhoods where crime.
He's like,
it's the same pattern,
repeating the same patterns over and
over and over again,
and no one has done anything to try to
socially engineer some beneficial change
in these communities.
Instead they just continue to lock up
the same people.
And I agree with him that that is
essentially at that point it becomes
institutionalized racism.
Right?
And that's a real issue.
And I think that that's the issue that
needs to be addressed.
And I don't think
that affirmative action is the best way
to do it because I think that also it,
it starts to produce this feeling of
resentment from people that are more
qualified,
that don't get the jobs well.
And I would think,
let's say for the,
for the black applicant who,
let's say goes to law school,
uh,
they,
they will never know whether they went
through the whole process simply on
their merit or whether they were helped
in some way.
And I think that itself won't know.
They'll be if they graduate.
No,
no,
no.
What I mean is when you got it,
did you,
did you get in strictly on the merits of
your Dosha?
Let's suppose I actually don't want a,
I'm a,
I'm a person of color and I don't want
anything to be effecting the decision
other than purely the merits of my dose
here.
So now I go through the process at the
end of that process,
I won't absolutely know for sure whether
it was strictly based on what I wanted,
which is the murder of my,
those here,
whether there was some,
uh,
something that helped me along the way
because of this institutionalized
affirmative action.
So there's not a bit problematic.
I guess it could be,
but I would assume that by the time
you've gone through university,
you know,
you're,
you're now you're talking about a much
higher level of education and it should
be pretty.
I hate to use the term black and white,
but it should be right there.
I mean,
you should see their grades and you see,
so are our professors are hired as a
function of these things.
What I once applied for real say this
here publicly,
I once applied,
so this is,
I was coming out on the market finishing
my phd,
uh,
on the market like a cow or since the
academic market.
And the academic market works is you,
you,
you interview round one and then route
in one place.
All the schools come there.
And then in round two they invite you
for a campus visit.
And so I had been,
I was interviewing at one of the most
prestigious places that you could ever
hope to imagine.
It's actually from your neck of the
woods in Boston,
Harvard,
right?
Uh,
maybe I shouldn't have said that and I
don't think you said that.
I did.
They have right salt kittings I'm not
admitting whether that's true or not,
but apparently I was one of the
finalists and at least I had heard from
some people who are maybe on the inside,
uh,
that they were really looking for a
woman and that to the extent that I
might not be able to articulate a might
be a problem.
So I don't know if that ended up being
the main reason why I think that the
job,
but I've often heard that,
uh,
you know,
you are not have the right race.
We need more diversity,
we need more gender diversity,
we need more racial diversity and make
it fair.
And even though,
I mean,
how has that ever achieved?
Well,
frankly,
it's good.
I think it's grotesque.
Look,
there was a,
I don't know if you saw,
I had a sad truth clip where I,
I titled it the All Time Greatest social
justice warriors.
It was based on a group of Dartmouth
students that had occupied,
I think the president's office with a
set of.
Have you seen,
have you seen this?
It's about the freedom project.
Maybe you can put it up.
So the Dartmouth freedom project where
they,
they had sort of like a manifesto,
here are the things that we absolutely
expect dartmouth to implement.
If you saw that list and I go through
some of that on my youtube channel,
it's simply baffling.
You know,
we have to have a,
a professor of Color Speaker series.
I mean think about that,
right?
I mean,
so if,
if,
if I'm,
if I'm a number theorist,
I'm a mathematician,
does the amount of melanin that I have
determined how I study the distribution
of prime numbers.
The idea that you would have students
demanding that there be a person of
color speaker series.
I mean it's grotesque,
right?
I mean we,
nobody's denying the fact that racism
has existed and to some extent continues
to exist,
but to have these types of demands to me
seems problematic.
Well,
I,
I definitely don't think it's the most
intellectual approach to the issue at
hand,
which is combating racism,
right?
I don't think it's making.
Instead of having an even playing field
for all and considering all with equal
merit to change the level of the playing
field and boost people up that aren't
qualified.
Right.
I think that's where you're talking also
about the end result.
You're talking about the finished
product of an education,
you know,
I mean literally at the highest level of
professor,
so I think that if you're looking at
that,
it really,
it all comes down to what is it that's
making certain people have less
opportunity and that needs to be
engineered from a societal level and
from a cultural level,
and it's.
I've said this many,
many times at the,
the biggest issue with any culture is
the weakest link,
right?
But what's the best way to have a more
successful country?
What's the best way to have a more
successful union will less losers?
Well,
how do you have less losers here?
We give more people education,
more people chances,
and more people who are disenfranchised
and we're stuck in these bad situations.
Give them an opportunity to get out some
way or another.
Whether it's through continued
education,
whether it's through community centers,
whether it's through combat,
I mean what will Larry elders talking
about better not having fathers?
Boy,
well we can't just say fuck them,
they should have a dad.
The Dad should get involved that,
that you're not going to fix people like
that.
The children are the ones that there are
still malleable and still have
potential.
So we have to figure out a way to
provide them with some sort of
resources.
I'm sort of some sort of
some sort of mentorship,
you know,
some,
some hope.
You know what I mean?
Let me,
let me just read through this carefully
because it's a thorny topic.
Earlier we spoke about the,
the culture of achievement that
we find that is that make within Jewish
homes.
Yes.
By the same token,
do you think that other cultures might
be creating environments that are
exactly the opposite of that?
In other words,
yes,
there might be some endemic
institutional reasons why people don't
succeed,
but there are also individual
responsibility or collective
responsibility within the family or the
culture.
I think just eluding to that.
We'll let.
We'll will cause people to level an
accusation of racism against you,
right?
I mean,
think about Bill Cosby,
Bill Cosby,
I know he's not popular now,
but at one point he was walking around
and saying exactly that,
right?
That,
that,
that blacks have to take responsibility
for some of their failures and he was
that that message was not very well
received.
Well,
he,
you know,
he's saying it from an easy place saying
it from someone who's very successful,
right?
I think.
I think people imitate their atmosphere.
I think culture's exists because it's
easy to pattern yourself around what's
around you and that's.
That exists in a religious sense and it
exists in a behavioral sense.
You,
you become a lot like the people that
you surround yourself with.
That's why it's so important to surround
yourself with positive people.
It's one of the most important lessons
you could ever learn as a human being.
The more positive people you surround
yourself with,
the more you'll aspire to be like them.
The more you you have a high standard
that exists all around you.
Well,
if you're fucked and you grow up in a
place without,
with no hope and a lot of despair.
I mean,
I remember when I first moved to New
York when I was in my early twenties and
uh,
I didn't really have that many friends
at first and it was,
and I had a few friends that I just,
I was really disappointed with them and
one of them because he just would say so
much racist shit,
it would drive me crazy and I just,
I wasn't,
I was almost like God damn it.
Like I can't find friends like I had in
Boston,
you know,
I was,
I had a bunch of knuckleheads that I
wish that I knew and I needed to
establish,
you know,
it takes a while when,
especially when you're young and by the
way,
no Internet back then.
So you're trying to find good friends
and friends that were like in my
profession as standup comics.
So I had to like,
you know,
get closer to a few people that are in
these communities.
And it took a long time.
But I remember feeling really depressed
when I first moved there and it was,
it was a cause for me to reconsider
moving back to Boston.
There was one point in time,
even though I had just signed with this
new manager that's still my manager to
this day and there's all this hope and
promise that like,
wow,
I'm actually going to have a career now.
I was so bummed out by the people that I
was around with that I would go back to
Boston and do gigs and I'd be like,
fuck,
I want to move back here man.
Because I was like Boston for all of its
faults and you know,
is a very smart place.
And as,
as New York.
But I had just,
I had infiltrated into a really great
community in Boston and I hadn't done
that yet in New York.
So there's a very small,
you know,
obviously a couple of years later I was
fine.
But it was when you're not around
positive people,
it doesn't feel good.
I was living in North New Jersey when I
first moved there because that's where
my grandfather lived and I didn't have
any money,
so I stayed with him for awhile and he
was in a terrible neighborhood and he
had bought a house there a long time ago
and the community had changed several
times and gotten worse and worse and the
kid next door before I had moved in,
I think somewhere around the time that I
was living there,
his door got broken down by the cops and
they was selling crack and it was,
it was,
it was real bad.
Right.
You know,
so I've felt depressed living there and
the environment that I've found myself
in my,
my grandmother had had a stroke so she
would moan.
And the grandmother who's a Mafia.
I runner,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was earlier in her life when she
was mobile,
but she had a,
she had a stroke and she,
she gave her 70,
like 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years and they were
like,
she's probably going to die.
Like she.
She had a really bad stroke,
but somehow she hung on by a thread for
a long time and you know,
my grandfather used to have to change
your sheets and she had bed sores
because she would just lay in one place.
She couldn't really move.
It was awful.
So that environment of being in this
really poor neighborhood,
being poor myself,
I had no fucking money being around bad,
like didn't have good friends.
It's depressing.
It's depressing now.
Obviously I had opportunity,
I had a career.
There's a way to get out of that,
but I got a taste.
I think even though the tiniest,
tiniest,
tiniest taste of despair,
what it's like to be stuck in a shit
situation now,
imagine being born in that situation
because I,
you know,
I moved there when I was in my twenties.
I was like 23 or something like that.
Imagine if I was there my whole life and
I just been around fucked up.
People had been sexually abused or
physically abused or you know,
my mother was selling crack or you know,
my brother was in jail or who knows,
he.
There's a lot of variables that can lead
to a terrible state of mind and it's
insanely hard to overcome the patterns
of the past and the patterns of your
environment and until we address that,
this idea of pulling yourself up by your
bootstraps,
it's fucking ridiculous.
The idea of,
well,
the cops wouldn't be shooting these
young black kids if they just didn't
commit crimes.
That's crazy.
That's crazy because it's not even.
It's not an even playing field.
It's not even for me,
comparing myself of 23 to myself,
a 48,
it's not that I have way more
opportunity now.
It's way easier.
Life.
It's way easier and way,
way,
way better friends way.
I've established a nice community with
my friends.
Do you still a form of a lot of new
friendships or do you have.
Yeah,
yeah.
I have new friendships.
Yeah,
I definitely sent you.
Well,
thank you.
I'm honored to be amongst that group
because of doing this podcast.
It's allowed me to communicate with some
really fascinating people and that
that's definitely allowed me to
formulate some new and it's allowed me
to evolve my perspective to examine my
own ideas and to,
you know,
I think all of us that,
that I'm friends with,
we've all experienced that sort of same
similar growth pattern because,
you know,
as you take in more information,
you communicate with each other about
things,
you kind of evolve ideas.
And
so there was a study done I think a
longitudinal study and I believe I
mentioned it in the book,
uh,
at Harvard,
I think the,
the,
the lead investigator,
I think his name is George French would
say I guess viola or Vegan,
I think that's his name.
And out of 75 years of research in terms
of what is sort of the number one
predictor that makes people happy or
content.
I can't remember the exact dependent
measure.
The number one thing was establishing
meaningful connections with others.
I mean 75 years of research out of a
million possible causal factors were
distilled to that.
One fact.
I would agree with that.
Exactly.
The mother's status.
People I know are lonely.
Exactly.
Your saddest people I know,
you know,
I know.
Um,
I know a few comedians don't have
comedian friends too,
which is really weird.
They're sort of ostracized by the
community in some weird way and those
people are really sad,
really sad or really lonely and really
weird.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know if we've ever mentioned
this and this on this podcast,
but uh,
if you take prisoners,
many of them will prefer to be in
general population where they might be
jumped and stabbed then raped than to be
put in solitary.
Precisely because solitary confinement
is the ultimate of punishments to a
social species,
right?
Yeah.
We need each other and these,
these biological requirements that we
don't consider because we meet them on a
daily basis,
you know,
that's one of them is getting outside
and you know,
I,
I feel it
often because of course in my career
there are two parts of me,
there is the cocoon and my study.
I'm working on a book and for the next
16 months I'm pretty much focused on
that and I become sort of a cave dweller
and of course there's the public side of
me which is very extroverted and social
and so on.
Once in a while when I've spent several
days very much cocooned and then I go
out even to me to graduate students to
discuss ideas or a friend,
I literally come back
refreshed in a way that is akin to
satiating a thirst or hunger or sexual
need.
Right.
I mean,
you genuinely feel that I went out with
Joe and we had coffee and I really
needed that.
Right,
that exactly that.
Yeah.
I think I feel like that all the time
when I see my friends,
you know,
I work with um,
my good friend Joey Diaz last night at
the comedy store and when I saw him,
you know,
I hadn't seen him a couple of days or
so.
I may see them all the time,
but I hadn't seen him and he gave me a
big hug and I'm hugging them.
I'm like,
ah,
so good to see this guy,
by the way,
you know,
what is hormonal marker
of hugging,
Lux release of oxytocin.
Makes Sense.
I mean,
a friend that I genuinely love and he
genuinely loves me.
We see each other big smiles,
big hug.
It's warm and it's awesome,
you know,
and when you don't have that in life,
you suffer.
When I first moved to La I had gone here
to uh,
to do some acting and I was here for a
couple of weeks and I didn't have any
friends again,
same sort of situation and I had gone,
you know,
like,
like maybe like two weeks being here and
really not really knowing anybody.
And this girl that I was working with on
the set gave me a hug and I remember
that hug felt so good and it didn't feel
good.
Like I wanted to fuck her.
Right.
It felt good,
like,
like warm,
like love,
like an actual person being kind to me,
you know?
Or else like I was so weirded out by
being in this strange place and living
in La and like I'd just gotten
accustomed to,
I just established like a community in
New York,
you know,
established some friends and I was just
starting to be happy in New York and all
something out in La.
Well,
so in Darwinian Psychiatry,
which is a field of psychiatry that
applies evolutionary principles,
there's this idea of.
So for example,
we've evolved in bands of about up to
150 people,
right?
Do you might've heard of raw robin
Dunbar's number?
Yes.
Yeah.
So the idea is a hundred and 50 people
you can keep in your social memory
exactly right,
because computationally you want to be
able to mark who's trustworthy,
who's not.
This guy reciprocated.
This guy doesn't once you get past one,
because it's very difficult to maintain
all these in your head.
Well,
so in the context of the environments in
which we've evolved,
small groups,
repeat interactions,
our need for social interaction is
certainly met.
On the other hand,
you could live in New York,
you're surrounded by 8 million people.
You think,
how could somebody be lonely when you
step outside and you bump into 17,000
people yet the rates of depression in
this very lonely place,
but yet very filled place as much
greater than 150.
Precisely because there is a mismatch
between the environment in which we've
evolved and the contemporary environment
and so that's in the field of
evolutionary psychiatry.
You study these types of things.
That's fascinating.
The mismatch is true and also there's an
intimacy wall that people put up because
there's too many folks,
right?
There's too many people and when there's
too many people,
you can't make friends with everybody.
Whereas if you're in a small town,
you wave to people as you're driving by,
you don't wave to people.
In New York you'd be.
You'd go fucking crazy.
Imagine if you had to wave to every cab
that passed you.
In New York,
if you're driving,
you just.
It's not possible so,
but in your case,
as somebody who obviously is as well
known and so on,
a lot of people are trying to be
friends.
You does that result in you having a bit
more of a precautionary approach with
people because you always think that
there might be some.
That doesn't have to be angle Aj,
I just want
to be,
you know,
friends with this famous person.
Does that ever come into play in your
interactions?
Yeah,
you definitely going to have that,
but you know,
you just find other likeminded people.
Just find people that are like you or
similar.
Similar.
Yeah.
You get to be picky,
you know,
and also there's,
there's a lot of weight to it,
you know,
if you like for you,
for example,
perfect example like you,
you start doing this podcast,
your podcast has taken off,
your youtube series is taken off and
then people want to become friends with
you because they think that they can get
on your show or piggy back on your
success and they,
they calculate and they look at you and
they say,
if I could just get in with the
Godfather,
I will be.
I'll be in and then I'll,
I'll get a youtube following.
Then I'll get a little twitter following
that I can get a career.
Like there's people that do calculate
things like that and I've met people
like that in the world of standup where
people have said,
hey,
you know,
take me under your wing.
Like,
what are you fucking crazy.
There's no wing.
Go,
go get your own way.
Yeah,
I don't have time.
I barely have time to do what I'm doing
right now and continue my own stuff like
you,
you see funny like,
but there's certain comics will see them
and I know they're really good and
they're working really hard and then
I'll take them on the road with me.
Like Tony Hinchcliffe is a perfect
example.
I think he was opening for you in
Montreal when you
take them with me everywhere.
And then there's other ones like that
where I meet them and they're,
they're working hard and they're,
they're hustling and then I can help
them,
you know?
But some people don't.
They don't want to work hard.
They just want to sort of cling on to
you like a lamprey and then they think
somehow know that'll take them to.
And you got to know who those people are
and some people don't.
And I have friends that don't,
they don't know,
so I'll be hanging around with them
like,
who the fuck is this guy?
And like,
oh,
he's a good guy.
He's a good guy.
I'm like,
wow,
what are you doing man?
What are you doing?
Like they'll bring these guys on the
road with them and they're.
They're terrible comedians.
But what they do is they know how to
stroke their ego and kiss their ass and
they've become a part of their system.
And the they,
a lot of my friends who have had this,
they had real problems with these people
where there's a deep resentment that
gets established when the person's
career doesn't take off.
Right?
You know,
it doesn't happen because they really
don't have that much talent.
They're just really good at kissing ass
and they get upset.
This person's not helping them.
Like,
what the fuck have you done?
You've let this knuckle head into your
life because they figured out a way how
to woo you and beginning.
So you have to be careful,
but you also have to be careful with
yourself.
You have to be careful with your own
behavior.
You have to,
you have to objectively monitor your own
thinking and you have to spend time
alone just thinking and that's something
that people don't like to do.
Right,
and that's something I think is
absolutely critical.
It's one of the most critical things for
a grown person to do is to spend some
time and just think alone,
just thinking and monitor your thoughts,
monitor your life,
and then go forth from that with some
directives,
with some ideas,
with some guidelines of what you want to
do and what you want to accomplish.
Because if you don't do that,
you sort of live life,
untethered,
untethered to your dreams or your ideas
or mean even dreams as far as like
community and family.
Like those aren't like lofty aspirations
and sent in the sense of like
unachievable things like climbing
everest in your underwear.
We're talking about things that can be
done but oftentimes aren't because you
don't pursue them.
With that director of like my directive
to establish a happy family,
to be a good friend,
to be a good neighbor,
to all these things,
people don't.
You oftentimes don't consider how much
of a factor those things play in your
overall happiness and the happiness of
the people around you.
You know,
and you can do that,
but you always have to think about it
earlier for,
of course your viewers don't know.
We I introduced you to.
One of my friends was an FBI special
agent and we were chatting.
I've been here for a few days,
so we had gone out together and I was
telling him that oftentimes I get an
itch for like a man's man,
companionship.
You know what I mean?
Yes.
Because I mean not not to stereotype,
but sometimes the intellectual types
with whom I can go out who are part of
my world,
who are my colleagues will will satisfy
a particular itch,
but of course I used to be a soccer
player and I'm,
I'm a guy's guy and I eat right.
I mean,
we need to be able to talk about certain
things that are not necessarily within
the confines need fellow sexist say it
fellow sexist,
but,
but fellow guys who can sort of let,
let let the hair down.
Right?
But you're allowed to be yourself and,
and I mean not,
not that I'm not myself and the other
guy,
but they are different sort of rules of
conduct and different settings,
right?
The way you act in way.
And uh,
and I find that recently maybe because
of course I think we both have young
children.
Were you somewhat cocoon?
I've lost a bit of the male bonding and
comradery that comes with playing in a
soccer team or under many,
many professional athletes as you know,
when they retire they will always say,
you know,
they don't miss playing in front of
100,000 people or the adulation,
but they miss the Camaraderie.
The Brotherhood would there and that,
that element of male male bonding is
something that sometimes I Miss Because
of how busy my life is.
Yes.
I completely agree.
And I've found that the most potent form
of that is hunting camps.
Okay.
That hunting camps,
when you go hunting and camping out and
you have a.
well,
you're focused on one thing and all
you're surrounded by these men and
everyone is allowed to be themselves and
you.
You were also,
you were in engaging in this intensely
quote unquote manly activity,
right?
That is almost the polar opposite of
raising children and coddling little
girls.
It,
it becomes this manly pursuit and it's
very satisfying.
Right?
Deep genetic level.
Exactly.
Because I think there's these reward
systems that are established thousands
of years ago in our DNA,
right?
It's like why you like being around a
campfire,
like why is that?
Because it's super beneficial to have a
fire wards off predators keeps you warm,
it cooks you off the mosquitoes,
the mosquitoes.
So many benefits to having this fire
that when you have one,
it's like naturally satisfying.
Ooh,
well,
you know,
we all huddled around it and you know,
it's odd to leave it,
you know,
it's.
I think that being around other men is
a.
it's oftentimes thought that these men
are going to get together and I think
men things come back and be sexist,
patriarchal,
and gonna come back and ruin all this
progress that we've had and there is
that idea that somehow or another that
manly is anti progressive and anti anti
equal anti equal rights and equal
values.
It's funny by the way,
that when you ask a lot of women what
types of Ben they want,
they will typically point to the male
archetype that is most viewed with the
stain by the current wave of third wave
feminism.
Right.
Talk to those women when they're being
honest and alone.
Yeah.
If they got called out by.
I mean,
so I,
I was wanting to communicating with the.
I think she was either Swedish or
Danish,
what she was saying that especially I
think she was Swedish where in Sweden
they had this sort of longstanding
experiment where they try to remove
gender pronouns.
Right.
Why don't you explain that?
Because it's very bizarre people.
Well,
the idea is that they're trying to,
as much as they can remove any gender
markers in any setting.
And so the idea is that we should be
gender neutral in every possible way.
Incidentally,
there was a study on toy preferences
done in Sweden,
right?
The,
the,
the Mecca of gender neutrality.
And guess what?
Little Boys and little girls gravitate
to exactly the same sex specific voices
everywhere else on earth core,
despite 40 years of a social
engineering.
It hasn't done anything,
but anyways.
And so,
so the men there have been so ravaged by
third wave feminism that,
I mean literally they're there,
they're there,
they have no testicles a lot,
metaphorically,
not literally,
uh,
and uh,
and so we were chatting on it,
whatever.
And she,
and she was saying that she misses the,
the pursuit.
I eman courting her.
I mean,
not sexually harassing her but,
but there is a sense that happens.
Well,
it's actually harassing
when you're not attracted to that man.
Exactly.
That's where it gets confusing,
right?
Because it's the right man,
you know,
Johnny Depp or something is,
is pursuing you.
It's,
it's hot.
If,
if some fat slob with dirty breath is
pursuing you harassment.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean that's
oftentimes and so men have become so
tentative,
it apparently and sweetness that
oftentimes these women,
the reason why they like guys,
you know,
sort of the stereotypical Italian guy
when they go,
it's not only of course Italian guys on
average American,
very stylish and good looking,
but it's because the,
that political correctness that has
stifled natural dynamics between men and
women hasn't fully
permeated,
say Italian culture so that when women
pass by,
yes,
you don't want them to be cat calling
them,
but guys will approach.
You guys will hit on.
You guys will tell you you're beautiful.
And in the deep recesses of even the
most ardent feminist,
you like that,
I mean,
that's part of the natural dynamics of
men and women.
Right?
But it's so confusing now for anyone
because you don't know.
I mean,
if I tell you,
you look good today at work,
is that sexual harassment or not?
Should I only tell my male colleague
that he really looks good in this time,
but I shouldn't.
Right?
Well,
the problem is if you are attracted to
this man and he tells you you look good
and you say why thank you,
and he's like,
yeah,
I'd love to stick my dick in your mouth.
Like,
okay,
you fucked it up.
You know,
it's
how far do people take it if it's a
gender or a sexual neutral thing,
like,
uh,
hey,
debra,
you look wonderful today.
I love your dress.
Look fantastic.
Well thank you Mike.
And then you know,
he goes to work and you go to work and
everybody's happy and you are friends.
There's a neutrality of sexual
neutrality there,
but that's the platonic values that
people would like to see in the
workplace.
Rarely exist.
There's always coveted sexual desires
that people,
their unrequited love and the affairs
that take place because people were
working together in these environments
for eight hours a day staring at each
other.
It's normal thoughts and ideas.
It's an,
it's an in.
It's an abnormal environment for men and
women to be in these,
in these workplaces and not have those
thoughts.
That's abnormal.
The thoughts,
I mean Matt and managing those thoughts
becomes incredibly tricky,
which is why you need to establish very
strict behavior and know laws and rules
and regulations in the workforce because
you don't want women to have to deal
with bullshit or men,
you know,
I've had men that were in here.
I had a guy,
the amazing atheist was talking about
this woman that he had that was like,
she was his boss and he was getting
sexually harassed,
like on a daily basis and it was
torturous.
It was brutal.
She would grab his ass who tried to get
him to fuck her and he didn't want to.
He wasn't attracted to her,
but she was an atheist.
Was the recipient of that.
Yes.
He's a youtube guy.
I don't have to show the drunken
peasants.
Yeah.
Good Dude.
Um,
and so,
you know,
he was talking about it from his
perspective where people don't look at
it like that he was in any sort of a bad
situation at all.
They laugh it off because he's mad.
Know was like,
what the fuck?
So he's like psychologically devastated.
He's got to go to work all the time.
This lady's Greg grab his ass and she's
gross.
She's above him.
Right?
And so he's experiencing what a lot of
women experienced.
Only no one
cares because he's a man,
you know.
It's like,
Oh,
speaking of not sexual harassment,
but continuing on that train of thought,
uh,
I had a public exchange with a woman who
started as trying to pass a bill,
I think in New Jersey.
Uh,
maybe in New York.
I can't remember.
It's called the rape by fraud.
Oh yeah,
I've seen that.
Yeah.
Have you seen it through me or I've seen
that law that they're trying to pass
this whole area.
So I explained the law because it's.
So.
The basic idea is that she's arguing
that when you,
in the same way that you enter a
contract with somebody and if you do so
under false pretense than you are
engaging in a fraudulent action.
Well,
when you get somebody to go to bed with
you under false pretense,
you lie about your background,
your education,
you learning about whatever,
and you get that person to acquiesce to
your advances.
And you have sex with them.
Well then that is a,
a,
an instantiation of rape by fraud,
right?
You,
you,
you were able to have sex with me under
false pretenses.
And so I saw this thing.
I thought it was breathtaking how
idiotic it was.
I said,
well,
okay,
let me put together a sad truth youtube
clip.
And in the clip I didn't mention her.
I didn't attack the woman who's trying
to move the,
the,
the idea.
But of course I linked back to her site
because I want to be judicious and link
show that it's a real thing.
The real thing.
Show them as,
as,
as a scientist.
So she,
she starts
hammering at me.
Uh,
she puts up this website.
I'm sure she could probably find them.
Maybe I shouldn't have given this
platform for her.
Uh,
maybe you shouldn't put it because
she'll just get more attention.
But anyways,
up,
she's saying that I am a rape by fraud
enabler.
So.
And then she goes on to say that you
better stop critiquing my ideas because
you're going to have a lawsuit from my
lawyer for being live.
And the family story to me,
so the mindset of person,
those words in roughly those words.
Yeah,
critiquing,
so maybe I'm paraphrasing,
but mean the fact that I'm coming after
her.
So this woman thought that her putting
up an idea in the marketplace of ideas
and having somebody scrutinize that idea
and harassment is harassment,
was a form of defamation.
It being libelous and I thought that was
just breathtaking and I had two other
cases with two for both happen to be
Forbes journalist,
female journalists where we went back
and forth it very,
very quickly.
This integrated on on twitter.
They started doing this year cyber
bullying me when I had done no such
thing.
I was very,
very tepid and so on and I used against
both of them.
Some.
Some people might have already heard
this story.
I use against both of them.
The fact that I
score higher on oppression Olympics or
victimology poker brown man from the
Middle East,
jus Arab,
overweight.
And so then I started moving on from
tell your story is a story that you told
them.
This podcast that's about as presses
again.
Exactly.
And so I turned it against them,
guess what?
They disappeared.
So imagine how grotesque their mindset
is.
As long as they thought they could say,
you know,
you're a pig,
you're cyber bullying me.
Maybe they need eat that.
Yeah,
twitter things.
Uh,
they felt safe.
The second I started,
I actually was satirizing saying,
why are you attacking a brown man?
Why are you attacking me?
Just because I'm overweight?
I have this beard faster than you could
say godfather because they knew that
they would be accused of Anti.
And I,
you literally use those things like,
you know,
you're an anti Semite you're in bureau
and,
and it works.
It's magical.
It's so stupid.
Why don't you just engage me in ideas
about identity politics?
Well,
I think there's some value in some merit
in the idea that you shouldn't be able
to lie to people and fuck them.
Right?
I think like if you say you're a prince
from another country and you want to
take this person to your land and they
will live forever in a garden of Eden,
and this woman thinks,
oh my God,
I met the perfect guy.
But it's not right by fraud.
Okay.
Well,
what is it?
No,
I actually in my,
in my clip,
I made it clear that I find that morally
and ethically reprehensible,
I believe that people should be
maximally honest in their daily affairs.
Exactly.
So,
but I don't call it rape by fraud.
You're okay.
It's not rape,
but what is it?
Duplicity.
It's caveat emptor,
buyer beware,
but there's something that we value very
intensely about intimacy.
And uh,
someone who achieves intimacy through
false pretenses.
It's,
it's different than someone that like,
uh,
you know,
says they're going to pay for lunch.
Ninety years old,
they're going to give you a million
dollars and they don't.
Okay.
But yeah,
I do.
Ninety five percent of online dating
would be then rape.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
It should be.
Should it be all rape,
right?
Men Lie about their education,
about their income,
their height.
Women lie about their age,
about their weight.
They wear pushup bras at part of the
mating ritual as,
as the testable as it might be,
is that people engage in deceptive
signaling.
Animals evolve deceptive signals.
Right?
So,
so that's called everybody a rape.
I mean everybody is a rapist.
Well,
under that you're getting real extreme
because we're,
we're talking about like what kind of
lies are we talking about where it would
be raped by fraud?
Like is it established?
Do they have certain parameters that
would.
So I don't know that achieved that.
This terminal.
The boundaries.
I think in her case,
I know that she has experienced
a very bad deception where the guy whom
she,
I don't know if she married him or not,
you know,
had said that he was ABC,
but it turned out to not be true.
And he had maybe,
okay,
it's dreadful.
It's horrible.
But that's,
that's called life.
I mean,
you learn from that.
I mean that happened to Cindy
[inaudible],
Cindy Crawford,
Christie Brinkley,
she married some guy,
she was in a helicopter crash with,
turned out to be kind of a con man.
And as time went on she realized it and
you know,
across to a lot of money.
Okay.
A woman who fakes an orgasm with you is
raping you because the next time,
the next time that you have sex with her
under the false pretense that you
received positive feedback that you're a
great lover because you gave her an
orgasm,
but she was faking her orgasm.
She's raping me,
so that's ridiculous.
So far off the beaten path because the
woman is saying like,
you gave her pleasure,
like it's.
There's no loss to you like that.
It doesn't hurt you in any way.
Like if that woman said like,
you made me come so because he made me
come,
I'm going to give you a million dollars
and then you can quit your job,
so you quit your job.
You're like,
I'm the best pussy eater ever.
I'm going to get paid for this,
and you quit your job because of that,
and then it turns out that she doesn't
really have a million dollars and you'd
even make her have an orgasm.
Well then you fucked up.
No,
the only reason I wanted to have sex
with her again is because of the
feedback I received for the great love
of your own pleasures of secondary
nature come out on the secondary.
I'm a very giving guy.
I'm completely all justice.
Such as stress.
You should abandon it immediately is a
terrible argument.
But I think there is,
there's a certain amount of validity to
what this woman saying like as far as
like someone who was like very
deceptive,
who uses that deception to have sex with
you and you find out they're a liar.
That feels terrible.
Yes.
So like,
but what should it be like,
what if,
you know what I mean?
What,
what,
what would,
what could it be mean if a guy says he's
a one eighth Indian,
you know,
my,
uh,
my mom's a patchy on my grandfather's
side,
no end,
but it's all bullshit when you're
attracted to that and some sort of
strange way because you really like a
dream catchers,
you know,
I've always wanted to be with a native
American and then you find out the guys
really like German,
Irish and you know,
he's a liar.
Like is that,
is that right?
Of course not right.
Okay.
So what is that?
That's just a liar.
What?
But when life,
when is it a problem?
It's a,
it's a problem.
When someone does it in somehow or
another,
it harms the person who's been deceived.
It becomes a crime,
right?
I think if there is,
I mean I don't know,
I'd have to think about what the
parameters are,
but I mean if,
if you,
if you were engaging in a repeat
interaction where you defrauded the
person through a misrepresentation,
but I mean the idea that to get somebody
to date you or have sex with you and
through the pursuit of that objective,
July as reprehensible,
that may be clear.
Again,
it's reprehensible and I certainly don't
live my life that way.
Although I'm married
now,
but I never have lived my life that way.
You can't criminalize a central feature
of human nature.
It is incumbent of on each individual to
do their homework.
I mean you do your due diligence and
find out if the guy that you're speaking
to is a Nigerian prince.
Right,
but doesn't this woman have a kind of
fairly fairly cut and dry parameters
that she's establishing?
I don't.
I.
You don't know why.
I don't know either.
If she did,
maybe that would give it more validity
of something that she's been thinking
about for a long time,
but I can never imagine that it would
ever be able to meet the standards of it
being called rape.
You know,
what's interesting about this
conversation is that what we're talking
about as a person who's been fucked over
and that person has gone out of their
way to make sure this never happens
again because they've been hurt,
they've been tortured.
I think you see a lot of that with like
really radical feminism in general.
What you see is a lot of women who their
interactions with men have not been
positive and unfortunately the
stereotype is that these are very
unattractive women.
Well,
if you're a very unattractive woman and
you go through life just being rejected
by man or being treated like shit by
men,
there's like a natural tendency to think
that men are terrible because they've
rejected.
Like maybe you're attracted to a man and
he.
He laughed at you and mocks you.
That.
I've seen that on the male side too,
and with a close friend.
I had a friend that I watched him evolve
into a woman hater.
He had aspirations and hopes,
find a good girl and he had this one
girl he was dating and she fucked him
over and then another girl fucked them
over and just women I'm working at
attracted to him and you know,
it just got darker and darker as he got
older and older to the point where he
genuinely would say like,
just generalized terrible things about
women like women.
They're all fucking Horace Mann.
They all just want your money.
They're all fucking pigs.
Fuck them.
Who gives a shit?
I hope they get raped.
Like you would say,
crazy shit like that.
And you'd be like,
whoa.
Like where did this come from?
Well,
it came from a lifetime of rejection and
associating women with a negative
feeling.
Right?
I'm attracted to them.
I come up to them,
they shit on me.
I'm attracted to them.
I come up to them to shit on me over and
over and over again to the point where
he broke,
you know,
he just,
it was easier for him to form these
generalizations and the act on these or
to have these in his mindset and I think
that this is the unfortunate reality
about sexual attraction in,
as it pertains to the dynamics of men
and women interacting with each other.
There's a lot going on there when you
look at unattractive of feminist versus
over,
over and over again,
you see one after the other,
after the other.
How do we,
there's a study that was done,
uh,
I think published in frontiers in human
neuroscience where they measured that
the ratio and administered a scale of
gender,
you know,
how much you score and masculinity
femininity,
if I remember correctly,
or dominance or something at a feminist
conference.
And the women were more masculinized at
that conference.
So there is empirical evidence for sort
of your anecdotal intuition.
It makes sense.
And also women that are forced to work,
you know,
they,
they've found that women in the
workplace generally develop more
testosterone,
right?
Yes,
yes.
Women that are forced to fend for
themselves generally develop more
testosterone.
It it,
it literally alters the way their
hormones,
so it's not that depending on the fields
that they go into,
they start off with more or less to
start strong.
So you're saying that it's their
response.
They're saying that they believe it is a
response to women being independent and
being forced to provide for themselves
that they develop more testosterone.
I don't know how the fuck they prove
that.
I don't know how he likes to see.
The problem is you would have to have
the exact same person with the exact
same genetics take two completely
different paths,
so you'd have to do with identical twins
with very similar input,
right?
Because like your jeans,
a lot of what's going on,
the way they express themselves is
dependent upon your environment,
your experiences.
There's a lot going on that simple.
I,
I think my last set truth clip was on
exactly that where I was arguing that
the whole idea of biological determinism
as applied to evolutionary psychology is
complete nonsense.
And one of the examples that I give is
exactly the words that you use,
which is that genes are turned on or off
as a function of environmental inputs.
Right?
So,
so the idea when people levy,
he's like,
Oh,
you're an evolutionary psychologist.
Also,
you believe everything is biologically
determined.
Somebody who says that is effectively
saying,
I understand nothing about biology,
right?
Yeah.
It's um,
it's very complex and only being
recently understood within the last
couple of decades.
So we're talking about a fairly new
science that is,
or a fairly new data I should say,
that a lot of people just haven't
accepted yet.
And it's very convenient to generalize
instead to not taking into account all
these incredibly complex variables that
determine whether a human being is this
way or that way,
whether they're more masculine and more.
It's like,
what have you had to do?
What?
How have you had to fend for yourself?
Have you had to get through life?
What,
what,
what have you had to do as far as like
who have you had to nurture and take
care of?
You know what?
There's a lot of variables that lead to
a person being a person and there's a
lot of different styles of people and
some men like really strong dominant
mother figure wives.
They love it.
That's what they want.
They want some woman to take care of
everything and tell them what to do.
I have friends like that.
They want that woman to yell at them and
tell them what to do it.
It alleviates a lot of questions and
choices and that's what they look
forward to and then I have other friends
that want the wife to be like some 19
fifties housewife from a,
from a movie where she was just leave it
to beaver.
You come home,
dinner's on the table,
she gives you a kiss and you know,
it's like real traditional values,
but there's feminists that we'll look at
that woman and she's an enemy
like that.
Her life,
although it makes her happy to exist in
this way,
they have a really.
A cooperative relationship,
doesn't have the right to that choice
and Amanda's never have the right to be
masculine.
Men Don't have a right to go on these
hunting camps.
First of all,
you should only eat vegetables,
you should be a Vegan,
you know,
and then in doing so you definitely
shouldn't be a hunter and you definitely
shouldn't be involved in masculine
sports or activities.
You definitely shouldn't enjoy
weightlifting or anything that's going
to make you more men because it'll make
you toxic.
You're a toxic masculinity.
That's hilarious.
Do we want to talk about quickly or.
I'm not that familiar with her other
than I've seen a couple of her videos
about video games and I'm like,
and they've also seen thunder foot stuff
on her,
which is really interesting.
Which explains that she had this
background in marketing and mass
marketing and you know,
is obviously whether or not she's
entirely invested in these ideas.
She's obviously aware that she's
marketing her ideas towards a very
specific group and she's got these Beta
males that cling to her and are attached
to which are hilarious human beings.
Have you heard my theory about the.
It's actually a real top secret fucker
strategy.
Excuse me.
Sneaker fucker.
Sneaker fuckers.
No,
I can't wait.
There you go.
That's,
I think it's.
I'm not sure if it was a term that was
introduced by Richard Dawkins.
I can't remember who it was,
but he called it speak if Dawkins called
misspeaking.
Maybe Jamie can pull it up,
but anyways,
it basically refers to some species
where males come in different
phenotypes,
in other words,
different physical manifestations,
so there might be,
say for example,
that type of fish species where the
typical male is a whatever,
a big big phenotype,
whatever that is.
Then there are other males that mimic
the phenotype of females,
so when the male standing around looking
to protect his area that that male who
looks like a female will sneak in and
then get some quick calculations with
some of the females that otherwise
should be inaccessible to him and that
became known as a sneaker fuckers
strategy in zoology and I argue I
haven't tested it,
but I think it it,
it,
it would,
it will be interesting to do so that
some of these sort of social justice
warrior,
Beta males are engaging in a form of
sneaker fuckers strategies.
What do you think?
One hundred percent,
100 percent.
Without a doubt.
I mean,
you have to do what you gotta do it.
There's a desperation involved,
like if you can't be,
you know,
this beautiful Stud Mail that all these
women falling.
I'm too short and too short.
I'm not existent and give me a chance.
You know,
you're shorter than me.
Dude.
You're fucking know I'm finished.
It's done.
But you know what?
There is research that shows this study.
Get ready defensive.
No,
not at all.
You're ready.
What?
So you bring in a guy to a room and only
thing that you manipulate is the
ascribed status,
academic status that you give to a guy.
He comes into a room and in one,
in one version of the experiment,
he's a assistant professor.
In the second version,
he's an associate professor of the third
version.
He's a famous world famous professor.
Then when he steps out,
the only thing that you test is people's
perception of his height.
His height magically becomes taller as
his ascribed academic status goes up.
And so I always joke that I may be only
from my phone,
but I'll tell you I'm seven foot four
baby.
I'll tell you that.
That's hurtful.
No,
it's not.
I feel safe.
I feel very uncomfortable.
I mean,
on a really good day where the Harris
Spike five,
600 actually.
Somebody really good data.
I was in a photo.
You'd measure that man.
Was it a photo yesterday with Dave
Rubin?
And I did his show and so on.
And somebody wrote.
He goes,
oh,
I learned something new.
I thought the Godfather was much taller.
We gotta wear stilts.
I got to wear stuff.
I got to wear the Rubio heels.
Maybe.
What's a Rubio Hill?
Rubio.
The,
the,
the presidential candidate has wasn't
he?
Wasn't there a rumor that he was patting
his heels?
Make himself real?
That's what I'd heard.
I don't know.
I wouldn't be shocked.
When you think about political circles
and what kind of manipulation matters.
Yeah.
There's so much manipulation going on
there with image and even so many
different consultants.
I mean they have that on television
shows.
I can only imagine what it would be
like.
Well,
when,
when George Bush was debating,
I don't know if it was carrie,
I can't remember which one,
uh,
his,
his camp had to come up with all sorts
of rules of what kind of camera shots
you can do and so on,
so that he doesn't look at his heels.
Isn't it beautiful how everything I say
is validated by Jamie Jesus Christ.
It's believable.
Fucking four inch heels on.
I love Jamie.
I should have him around everywhere.
Like when I'm in class I say something
and he just pops this stuff up.
First of all,
those would be seriously uncomfortable.
Well,
okay.
Well hold on,
hold on.
Now.
How much taller those things in like
cowboy boots,
cowboy boots or like that?
That's at least three inches.
Those are bigger than three inches.
Those are.
Well maybe you're right.
Those are giant.
So he's a short guy.
How tall is Rubio?
I.
Oh yeah,
he has giant heels because look at those
Italian shoes.
That's not normal for those ones on the
left.
That's not normal that that's by design.
Yeah,
there you go.
You got to just suck it up,
man.
Deal with the height
is five foot six.
He could get any woman he wants in the
world.
Who's that guy?
Oh,
for the love of God.
What are you talking about?
Lionelle.
Messy.
You don't know who that is?
No.
Who is that?
Why you're looking at me?
Funny.
Last time it was demetrius mighty mouse.
Johnson.
I don't know.
Those tend to shut your mouth.
Greatest pound for pound fighter in
several lived.
Dare you?
Leah now is the greatest soccer player
who ever lived.
Oh,
soccer.
That's okay.
Right?
But the godly
sport he ever really.
It's just not something I'm interested
in.
This one is five foot six.
He said,
you know what?
I saw that guy on television.
They were doing some special on his,
uh,
his,
his movement and what he can do to
balls.
Not like my balls but like soccer balls
and how he can manipulate them.
And it was fucking spectacular.
He's an incredible,
incredible athlete,
but I didn't know what his name was.
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
You should,
you should.
You should show his wife at some point.
I'm sure she's not as fuck.
It's okay.
You don't show it.
I get it,
but um,
yeah,
but this guy running for president as
nothing to do,
like she's as Christ the guy's boring.
Nobody gives a fuck.
It's not a leader.
It's like Jeb Bush.
Jeb Bush,
not a leader.
That's why you had to back out of it.
You know Ted Cruz,
not a leader.
You know,
they're,
they're hanging their hat on this guy
that most people see right through
because there's certain,
there's a,
there's a thing that happens when you
talk to that guy where his intellect,
like Ted Cruz,
like maybe he's intelligent.
Maybes I don't,
I don't know.
Supposedly went to Harvard supposedly is
very wise.
The way he talks,
the way he establishes himself,
the way he communicates is not enough.
It's not enough to run the world.
We all recognize it.
He,
he's not.
He's not powerful enough in his ideas.
Bernie sanders might be a crazy old
socialist.
He might be,
but when that guy speaks with passion,
like I buy it,
you buy it.
It doesn't exude a wind penis.
No,
it doesn't exude a wimp.
He's got terrible posture.
He's got terrible posture,
he looks very unhealthy,
but he's willing to stand up for his
beliefs and he speaks with clarity and
he speaks with a certain amount of
force.
And uh,
I don't think,
I don't think he's the king,
you know,
but I think we live in a time where only
assholes want to be president.
You know,
look this,
this president thing is not going to
last.
It's not,
it's not going to last.
No,
I think it's like fucking,
it's like a Morse code.
It's like we need something better.
Like this is stupid.
It's like we have Morse code and we also
have cell phones.
Well,
you're not gonna use fucking Morse code.
It's goofy.
And this Internet thing that we have
created this way of establishing
information or expressing information,
it is so far superior to anything that
existed back when they invented the
electoral college or representative
government that,
that voting and,
and having a leader,
one single hire,
primate leader,
one singer,
single top eight that runs all the other
apes.
It's dumb.
You can't one person being president.
He's a fucking really stupid idea.
It just doesn't make any sense,
but who makes the decisions?
That should be a lot of people should be
a gigantic council of really intelligent
governance.
Yes.
One hundred percent.
I think it is already.
It is already.
It's a figurehead more than it is
anything.
If that doesn't explain why Obama
shifted almost all of his policies that
he said that he was going to do once he
got into office,
once he actually got into office,
change.
So many of the things he including his
idea and stance on whistleblowers.
There was a big part of his hope and
change website that they had to redact.
So who?
Who believes that the president really
is responsible for the entire country
really is the one guy that runs the
entire show,
I think almost no one now.
Almost no one,
so it's a ridiculous figurehead position
that I think we need to stop.
We need to stop pretending that we have
a king.
We need to stop.
We need to figure out a way to have an
effective form of government with a
giant group of really intelligent people
that vote on it.
People that have proven to be
intelligent and objective and well
educated and have a reasonable reason to
response to all these different various
the parliamentary system of the US,
Canada or Britain would probably be more
akin to what you're talking about maybe,
but you still have trudeau.
I mean you still have a figurehead,
you still have a one.
Figurehead is a bad idea and I think
it's a bad idea because I think that
this hope and this idea that we need a
king,
we need a a number one primate.
I mean that's really what it is.
It's these are like chimpanzee hierarchy
systems that have existed for thousands
and millions of years,
but you don't think that humans succumb
to the same dominance hierarchies.
I just don't think we need it anymore.
So I think we're moving towards this
idea of a global community moving
towards this idea of a,
of a world with the boundaries that we
have had in the past oftentimes have
been because we try to stay safe.
We try to establish borders.
We want to stay safe.
I want to keep people together and to
keep all the outsiders out.
We need a king.
We need a king to king,
to the guard.
The border is a king to lead us into
war.
I just think that's less and less
relevant today and that it's more and
more relevant to have a large group of
very informed people that can help a
large group of people that are
collectively calling themselves a
country.
Plato talks about philosopher kicks,
right?
He talks about that.
Those who should lead should be the wise
philosophers and assuming you sort of an
amalgamation of those guys,
be the Godfather.
Maybe they,
you were born in another country.
You're fighting,
but you're changing the constitution for
me.
Ah,
we tried for Arnold Schwarzenegger until
he got popped.
Right.
But what's the deal with him now doing
those video game commercials?
I mean,
does it not seem goodness,
scratch paper,
I'm going to pay for that divorce.
A lot of money.
I bought it.
I mean he's doing movies,
doing a lot of different things.
So I probably came to him with a big
deal and you know,
it's a funny commercial and they're all
attacking.
I'm trying to get an iphone.
Yeah.
Fuck.
It doesn't bother me.
It's a bother,
you know.
But I mean it seems like for former
governor.
Yeah,
I mean maybe it's governor anymore.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
But I don't spend too much time thinking
about it.
I mean,
it would be weird if push started doing
one of those Bush.
The president what it.
Yeah.
The current guy,
you know,
the,
the former president,
President George W started doing a
commercial for a video game where he's
running away from a bunch of assassins
are trying to steal his phone.
It would get really weird.
Right.
You know,
or if Obama left office and started
doing commercials for Shit,
you know,
I mean is there a law against that?
If a black president doing commercials,
like a former president,
like representing Pepsi Cola or
something like that.
And I suspect not.
What would be the law and would fall
under what rubric?
I don't know.
I just.
You never seen it?
No wonder why a violation,
if you like,
in quotes of the presidential office.
Right?
Well,
I think one thing that would hinder them
is the financial reward of being a
president is really about those gigantic
speeches that they give.
You know,
Hillary Clinton.
Here's,
here's a fucking a crazy one.
Hillary Clinton and Bill Clinton have
made hundreds of millions of dollars in
speeches.
They gave their daughter a $3,000,000
wedding party,
$3,000,000.
The masses,
they're just like you and me will.
This just should show you how insanely
fucked up political system in this
country,
and that's why a president,
it would actually be a negative to them
if they had any mark on their record
like doing a pepsi commercial,
I can.
Whatever Pepsi would pay them,
it wouldn't be enough because like a guy
like Bill Clinton,
he makes unfucking believable amounts of
money and he was at least a partially
disgraced president,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still didn't harm his financial.
The financial possibilities.
Do you think it'll ever be the case
where a sitting US president can claim
to be an atheist?
I think an agnostic is more likely than
an actual atheist in the atheist is
someone who says,
I don't believe in God.
No,
God,
no.
I think more likely someone that could
say,
I don't know about you know,
or someone who is.
Is there anybody that chooses to engage
in a bunch of different traditional
practices of worship but doesn't
necessarily believe in the God has as a
politician,
someone who tries to go into a Jewish
synagogue and then one day and then do
all these trades when it's campaigning
season I put do they wear the garb and
do cert,
the service,
so I could send you a photo.
Ether police pulled them up.
There's a bunch of photos of Justin
Trudeau being able to.
I'm done with that guy too to show he's.
He's in every extremist mosque in
Canada.
Prostrating himself as a,
as a,
as a sort of a Muslim that.
Did he do that to get into the office a
lot?
What else would he have done then?
Once he's in office,
then how does he behave?
I'm not sure.
It's only been 100 days,
so we'll have to.
I reserved judgment,
but uh,
I'm not sure that I liked that very
much.
Yeah.
Well,
it's problematic when you support any
ideologies that really just don't make
sense.
Yeah.
And that's,
we're not talking about like meditation
or anything else where you're talking
about like really strict guidelines for
living and they don't make sense and
they're,
they're ancient,
you know,
in a lot of ways.
Those places where those guidelines were
established.
Where was the cradle of civilization
where civilization first emanate in
first took off and I have this sort of
joke that I never,
I never really figured out how to do it
on stage,
but that essentially the Middle East is
like the townies of the world.
Do you know what a townie?
Yes.
Actually,
last time we were on,
I didn't know that that terminal west.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
We talked about it last time.
It's just like think that patterns are
intensely hard to break and it's one of
the reasons why the United States is the
most as far as like artistically one of
the most diverse places in the world and
as far as our ability to express
ourselves in film,
in music,
in standup comedy and things along those
lines and even in podcasting,
it's the most diverse and the most
potent and it's because we're the people
that escaped exactly all the other
spots.
You know,
my,
my grandparents came from Italy and
Ireland and they all came over on a boat
when they were young and they
established themselves in the east coast
and that's where my parents were born
and that's where I was born and it's,
these are just like cup second,
third generation immigrants that we're
trying to get the fuck away from the
horrors of Europe and they tried to find
a new place with new opportunity and the
escape.
The tradition of the past and the
tradition of this new place was
different.
It was different.
It was more open,
it was more more.
There was more hope.
There was,
there wasn't a caste system,
you know,
like there is an England,
I mean there's like a very clear class
system that goes on in a lot of
countries throughout the world that has
existed back from the days when they had
kings.
By the way in Canada,
the Canadian government,
I can't remember exactly when,
specifically to avoid that caste system.
The,
the,
the royal caste system,
uh,
made it a law that Canadians can't be
knighted because any country that's
under the Commonwealth,
so you're Nigerian or you're Indian,
you could be knighted by the queen.
You become sir dame so on.
Canadians can't.
Precisely because the argument was that
the Canadian ethos is contrary to having
these hierarchical,
royal titles.
So I could never be served godfather
good.
I liked that.
You don't want to be assertive.
I think there's real problems in a
established caste systems like that.
Real problems that are intensely hard to
break.
And I think that the beauty of America
is that you can come here with nothing
and become somebody.
And the real lesson in that is not that
America is different.
It's really everybody is somebody being
held back by tradition and you're being
held back by these,
these parameters and these,
these guidelines that are set in place
by people that had a very limited amount
of information to work with.
They didn't,
they didn't understand the consequences
of these rules.
They didn't understand the consequences
of these,
these patterns of behavior that you're
forcing people to follow in.
And that's why America,
you know,
in a lot of ways represents still like
the beacon of freedom to people.
I mean there's a lot of problems with
America,
huge amount of problems with America,
but that alone that it represents the
most recent of the big countries,
the most recent of the nation.
And I don't know if it's coincidentally
the big one,
right?
The super power.
I mean,
I don't know if that's a coincidence.
Earlier we were talking about
friendships,
so let me link that to some of the stuff
that you're talking about America.
So one of the arguments as to why
Americans seem to form more sort of
Ephemera,
transient friendships,
you know,
not as.
I mean,
it might be a stereotype,
but I can tell you that when I was a
graduate student in the,
in the US,
all the non American students complained
that Americans are very quick to be
friendly with you,
but they don't form the same tight
bonds.
That's interesting.
I've never heard that before,
but listen to the story.
So I thought about it and I thought,
well that can't be.
It can't be inherently that Americans
are more shallow.
So what might be some reasons,
and so I actually talk about this,
not in this book,
but in an earlier book of mine,
2007 book that the fact that Americans
face greater geographic mobility today.
I could be in Boston tomorrow.
I can be an la and socioeconomic
mobility.
The stratum that I was born into is not
necessarily the one that I might die in.
So because of these various forms of
mobility,
it creates a more transient,
a definition of friendship.
Not that Americans can form strong
bonds,
but there is a bit of a shallowness to
the original encounters because tomorrow
I might be somewhere else.
Whereas the guy who comes from Lebanon,
where,
where he's born as,
where he's going to die,
where his word is,
as this contract is going to have a
different definition of friendship if
only because life is not as anonymous.
It's not as open to mobility as it would
be the case in say,
California.
That seems reasonable.
It makes sense.
That makes sense.
You know,
I,
I think,
uh,
I probably saw you,
I saw you.
I saw you trying to poke a hole into it.
Makes Sense.
I mean we are in a lot of ways.
I'm captive by the initial impulses of
the people who created us and the land
that they established,
you know,
in this place was established by people
that were,
were,
were so transient.
They,
they got in a boat and they sailed away
before they had pictures.
But you know,
I mean,
there wasn't even fucking pictures when
people came here in the 17 hundreds.
They had a draw things,
you know,
you should look at this drawing.
This is what's waiting for you on the
other side of the ocean.
It's only going to take three months.
Don't be a pussy and you're likely to
die.
People don't want to get on a fucking
plane for 10 hours and go to England.
Oh,
that's too far,
but people.
But that's a fucking dot.
Even a day.
You could wake up in,
in,
in Los Angeles,
get on a plane.
You could have dinner in London.
That's incredible.
That's insane.
Is it Louis?
Is it Louis Ck?
Is that how you pronounce it?
Is he the one who does the bit where he
says about how you know he's flying in a
tube in the sky?
Yeah,
the Wifi Joe.
Yeah.
Well we.
It's all relative,
right?
What's,
what's ridiculously easy to us in
comparison to our grandparents is going
to be a joke to our grandchildren who
could beat beam each other on the moon
anytime they want.
Let's just go to the base on Mars and
your kid's going to go to Mars today.
Now there's going to fucking beam each
other up all over the galaxy.
I mean,
that's what we're.
We're dealing with a very strange and
ever changing world,
so very nice.
Just a fucking bad ass podcasts,
brother.
Man.
You already do.
This is your thing,
man.
I,
I live a truly blessed life to know guys
like I do.
I know guys like using what makes this
podcast so cool to be able to have
conversations with guys like you so
much.
This is your future,
man.
This is what it is.
He's fucking stuffy classrooms with 20
fucking kids who barely pay attention.
Who are judging you.
Fuck those people.
Fuck.
Fuck them.
I don't listen to the universities.
Don't listen to him.
Don't hire him.
Let him make so much more money doing
this.
Anyway.
I'm your youtube pages,
so youtube slash.
See Slash got sad.
It's the sad truth,
a sad truth.
S A,
a d truth s a,
a d,
but it's not sad.
It's not sad.
It's happy.
I'm always smiling,
always smiling.
God,
sad.
G A,
D,
s a d is my twitter feed and then my
public facebook page,
whatever they start.
Dr. Period.
Gad periods set.
Always pleasure my brother.
Thank you.
So,
but invitation anytime you want.
Come on back on like we can do this
every day.
Thank you so much.
Bye Bye.
Cheers.
Goodnight everybody.
Okay.